bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne l'audition des ministres
pierre moscovessi et Jérôme Cahusac par
la commission des finances du Sénat
l'objectif de cette audition est de
préparer l'examen du budget qui sera
débattu en séance publique au Sénat à
partir du Lundi 29 octobre je vous
rappelle que le budget pour 2013 qui a
été adopté vendredi en conseil des
ministres prévoit un effort sans
précédent de 30 milliards d'euros
d'économie divisé en 10 milliards
d'euros de restriction de dépenses pour
l'État 10 milliards d'impôts
supplémentaires pour les ménages et 10
milliards d'impôts pour les entreprises
l'objectif de ce budget qualifié de
combat et de ramener le déficit public
de la France à 3 % du produit intérieur
brut pour 2013 alors qu'en pensent les
sénateur et bien élément de réponse avec
cette audition bonne matinée à tous
monsieur le rapporteur
général mes chers
collègues nous allons
débuter cette séance
d'audition donc je demande à celles et
ceux qui nous
rejoignent de bien vouloir
installer je salue les les les les
membres de la presse et les différentes
personnes qui ont répondu à notre
invitation cette audition monsieur le
ministre du Budget va commencer avec
vous et se poursuivre avec Pierre
Moscovici ministre de l'économie qui va
nous
rejoindre c'est une
audition un peu particulière pour
différentes raisons d'abord parce que
usuellement
la commission des finances du Sénat bien
sûr après celle de l'Assemblée nationale
et avec beaucoup de révérence vis-à-vis
de celle de l'Assemblée nationale que
vous avez présidé et a l'habitude
d'entendre les ministres dès la
présentation du projet de budget au
Conseil des
ministres alors cette année le
calendrier ne s'y prêtait pas tout à
fait parce que c'était un vendredi et
sans vouloir faire un jure à notre
disponibilité à notre sens des priorités
je je pense qu'il est quand même
probable que vous auriez eu moins
d'auditeurs vendredi après-midi de la
semaine dernière et et d'autre part et
surtout quelques jours ne sont pas de
trop pour examiner de tels documents qui
pèsent très lourd
et qui peuvent
susciter de notre part et de la part de
nos collaborateurs quelques analyses
alors monsieur le ministre délégué au
Budget je pense que les uns et les
autres connaissent déjà dans leur grande
lignes les documents que le Conseil des
ministres a approuvé bien entendu
vous nous direz dans votre exposé
introductif qui m'avez-vous dit sera
bref selon votre habitude votre habitude
participative n'est-ce pas donc vous
nous direz ce qui vous semble essentiel
et ensuite nous vous poserons une une
série de de de
questions le rapporteur général et
moi-même et l'ensemble des des collègues
ici présents alors ce ce ce budget pour
avec un objectif de de 3
% budget
d'effort budget qui va
nécessiter la la mobilisation
et vous l'avez élaboré sans doute un peu
dans la douleur comme il est inévitable
et à présent vous nous le vous nous le
présenter et les membres de la
commission des finances et les personnes
qui ont bien voulu les rejoindre sont
très attentive à vos
propos merci monsieur le Président
permettez-moi d'abord de bien vouloir
excuser Pierre Moscovici qui pour des
raisons personnelles absolument
drimantes ne peut pas être présent
strictement à l'heure de votre
commission des finances il est prévu
qu'il nous rejoigne ce que nous avons
fait avec lui devant vos homologues de
la commission des finan de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est présenter ce powerp don
dont je crains que cette présentation
précisément ne soit pas de la briveté
que peut-être vous espériez mais n moi
je je suggère de faire cette
présentation sauf si vous souhaitez que
je résume la dite présentation pour
laisser la place au débat et aux
questions moi je suis vraiment à votre
disposition à cet égard il est vrai que
c'est diapositif que je m' prête à vous
présenter le cas à vous commenter sont
pour la totalité ou peu s'en faut connus
euh du Sénat et des membres de la
commission et donc peut-être sous le
contrôle du rapporteur général et selon
son avis auquel je me remets bien bien
volontiers euh peut-être pourriez-vous
nous dire l'essentiel de cette
présentation et ensuite nous aurions
plus de temps pour l'interactivité mais
mais maisacord faisons comme ça faisons
comme ça il a pas d'objection de la part
du Rapp
enfin pardon moi je vois pas d'objection
par parfait bon alors c'est c'est un
c'est un budget vous l'avez dit
vous-même qui fut difficile à élaboré
car plusieurs contraintes présidaient à
sa
naissance la première qui fut
constamment rappelée par le Président de
la République quand il était candidat et
depuis qu'il a été élu et de respecter
la parole de la France c'est-à-dire
présenter un budget qui affirme que le
déficit public se réduira de 4,5 % du
PIB à 3 % du PIB entre 2012 et 2013
c'est-à-dire un effort de 30 milliards
d'euros et découvrir aujourd'hui j'ai
cru comprendre que certains
naturellement pas dans cette enceinte
mais que ailleurs que certains fassent
semblant de découvrir qu'un effort de 30
milliards d'euros était nécessaire m'a
paru surprenant tant il est vrai que cet
effort était inscrit dans la trajectoire
de finances publiques que notre pays
avait présenté à la commission et à nos
partenaires il y a de cela 2 ans
maintenant nous nous inscrivons dans
cette trajectoire parce que c'est la
parole de la France qui est en engagé il
faut donc faire un effort de 30
milliards d'euros et le choix que nous
avons fait est un choix
de d'économie pour un/ers de fiscalité
pour les 2/ers à part égal ménage et
entreprise alors il faut naturellement
que je m'explique sur ce choix qui
repose sur plusieurs raisons la première
est que à court terme pas forcément à
moyen à long terme mais à court terme la
réduction de la dépense publique est
plus récessive que la hausse de la F
fcalité je dis bien à court terme or
dans la contrainte qui est la nôtre 3 %
dans la volonté qui est aussi celle du
gouvernement et du président de la
République qui est de tenir les
engagements qui ont été pris il y a
aussi une nécessité qui est de préserver
autant que faire ce peut la croissance
l'année prochaine vous savez que ce
budget est fondé sur une hypothèse de
croissance de 0,8 % tout faire pour
préserver cette croissance commander
évidemment de faire des économies car
celles-ci sont indispensables mais
commander aussi d'être prudent en la
matière pour ne pas compromettre la
croissance de l'année prochaine prudent
encore que il me paraît difficile de
faire davantage d'économie que ce que
nous proposons au Parlement avec la
présentation de ce projet de budget en
effet depuis la prise de fonction
jusqu'à la présentation de votre de
votre commission ce sont donc 250
millions d'euros qui chaque jour ont été
trouvés pour faire des économies si vous
divisez les 10 milliards par le nombre
de jour d'exercice du gouvernement
auquel j'appartiens vous arrivez à ce
ratio de 250 millions d'euros d'économie
par jour trouvé aucun gouvernement n'a
fait davantage jamais peut-être certains
regrettent-il aujourd'hui que certains
dirigeants n'ai pas fait plus mais en
tout cas dans notre histoire politique
économique en tout cas contemporaine
aucun gouvernement n'a fait autant
d'économie sur un projet de
budget par ailleurs ces économies sont
assez équitablement réparties entre le
fonctionnement l'investissement entre
l'effort demander à la Défense nationale
et bien sûr les dépenses d'intervention
et ces 10 milliards d'euros d'économie
sont netes j'insiste net des mesures
nouvelles contenues dans ce budget
mesures nouvelles qui concernent le
l'éducation nationale la sécurité la
justice on va rester sur cette
diapositive voilà la sécurité la justice
et bien sûr l'emploi vous voyez
s'afficher ce que sont les économies en
fonctionnement 2,8 milliards OS c'est un
effort de 5 % qui est consenti par
toutes les administrations en moyenne
les autres entités à l'effort de
redressement sont pour l'essentiel les
opérateurs mais d'autres également et
sur les opérateurs il me semble qu'il y
a une action collective à mener qui
serait d'importance les opérateurs c'est
plus d'un millier d'entités c'est un
budget pour l'état de 40 milliards
d'euros ce sont des taxes affectées pour
10 milliards d'euros les opérateurs ce
sont ces 5 dernières années des
structures dont les frais de
fonctionnement ont augmenté de 6 % quand
ceux de l'État baissé de 6 ce sont des
entités qui ont dépassé de 13 % le
plafond d'équivalent temp plein quand
vous savez que pour l'État la règle du
1/ 2 s'appliquait elle fut critiqué mais
elle s'appliquaient ce sont des
structures qui d'une certaine manière se
sont affranchies des services de l'État
qui pourtant sont là pour les contrôler
affranchi à un point tel qu'ils estiment
que les taxes affectées leur
appartiennent et que quand il y a du
surplus il ne s'agit pas de le rendre à
l'état mais de trouver de nouvelles
missions pour justifier l'utilisation de
ce surplu il y a un effort considérable
à faire ce budget le démarre en
plafonnant un pourcentage non
négligeable des taxes affectées aux
opérateurs et je pense que le Parlement
qu'il s'agisse de l'Assemblée ou de la
Haute Assemblée pourrait utilement me
semble-t-il aider pouvoir exécutif à cet
égard pour la défense de,2 milliards
d'euros c'est un budget de transition et
ça n'est pas un budget de rupture c'est
d'ailleurs un budget qui respecte les
lois de programmation s'il ne respecte
pas certaines prescriptions du Livre
blanc mais aucun des programmes
militaires d'investissement n'est stoppé
c'est donc bien un budget de transition
et c'est aussi un budget qui permettra
l'accueil dans des conditions correctes
et dignes de nos troupes lorsqu'elles
seront rapatrié d'aghanistan vous savez
que la chose est imminente des économies
également pour dans les interventions de
l'État vous le voyez de milliards
d'euros et enfin les économies pour
l'investissement c'est là que ce
chapitre fut écrit le plus
douloureusement en matière d'économie
les élus que vous êtes et et que je
suis save qu'il est toujours délicat de
sabrer dans les dépens d'investisement
mais pour autant les choses surfaites et
je voudrais remercier à cet égard aussi
bien le ministère des Transports de la
culture que de la justice qui ont
compris la nécessité qu'il y avait à
tout le moins de décaler un certain
nombre de projets d'investissement ces
économies une fois faites et de lors que
l'on connaît la structure du budget on
met de côté les prélèvements sur
recettes qui pourtant sont sous la norme
on met de côté l'évolution des pensions
et de la dette et on arrive au cœur du
budget de l'État c'est-à-dire un peu
moins de 200 millions milliards d'euros
199,1 milliards d'euros c'est ça le le
cœur de l'action de l'État vous le voyez
s'inscrire là donc vous avez l'animation
va le montrer le prélèvement sur recette
pour l'Union européenne celui pour les
collectivités territoriales les taxes
affectées vous avez ensuite les crédits
du budget général hors dett et pensions
et vous avez donc ce budget de 199,1
milliard d'euros en baisse en valeur
absolue par rapport à l'fi 2012 de 700
millions d'euros en baisse en valeur
absolue par rapport à la LFI 2012 mais
avec une économie de 10 milliards par
rapport à la tendance car c'est toujours
ainsi ai que furent jugé les économies
réalisées donc un effort important très
important sur les crédits des ministères
certains contribuant plus que d'autres
avec les moyennes que je me suis permis
de vous indiquer ces économies étaient
nécessaires parce que l'État se doit
être efficient je crois qu'elle l'était
aussi pour que nos concitoyens qui vont
devoir concéder pour ceux qui sont
concernés l'effort fiscal n'ai pas le
sentiment que l'on demande tout à la
fiscalité alors pour ceux qui auraient
souhaité davantage je voudrais quand
même indiquer ce que sont l'évolution ce
qu'ont été l'évolution de la dépense
publique ces 10 dernières années ce
qu'elle sera dans les 5 années à venir
entre 2002 et 2007 l'évolution de la
dépense publique a été de 2,3 % je crois
entre 2007 et 2011 l'évolution de la
dépense publique a été de 1,7 % et nous
prévoyons une évolution à la dépense
publique toutes administrations
publiques confondu entre 2012 et 2017 de
0,7 % nous faisons donc un effort qui
n'a jamais été consenti pour l'instant
par les différentes administrations
publiques qu'il s'agisse de l'État qu'il
s'agisse de la protection sociale ou il
s'agit bien sûr des collectivités
territoriales les efforts devront donc
être partagés et solidaires tant il est
vrai que l'État à lui tout seul ne peut
évidemment résorbé l'endettement auquel
notre pays est soumis faire davantage
sera naturellement suggéré par certains
à titre d'indication je voudrais dire
que 20 milliards d'euros c'est la moitié
du budget de l'Éducation nationale
que aller au-delà des 10 milliards
d'euros pour faire par exemple 20
milliards d'euros d'économie c'est
supprimer d'un coup d' seul et d'une
année sur l'autre 500000 postes dans la
fonction publique d'État on peut
toujours imaginer que la chose serait
possible mais dè lors que l'on discute
de façon responsable on sait que ça
n'est pas le cas et c'est parce que nous
maintiendrons la norme zéro valeur des
dépenses de l'État hors dette et pension
que progressivement ces économies vont
monter en puissance au cours de la
mandature quand dans le même temps la
fiscalité elle sera stable car il faut
qu'il y ait une forme de stabilité
fiscale une fois que l'effort 2013 aura
été consenti pour en fin de mandature
arriver à ce ratio quel le président de
la République s'est engagé un
redressement qui se fera à parité par
des économies et par de la fiscalité la
fiscalité j maintenant à la fois les
ménages et les entreprises avec à chaque
fois deux préoccupations ne pas
solliciter des agents économique qui
pourrait amener de leur part des
comportements compromettant la
croissance et par ailleurs solliciter
les agents avec un sentiment aigu de le
faire dans la justice la plus aboutie
possible c'est vrai pour les ménages car
dans C loi de finance initiale il est
exact de dire que ne sont sollicités
qu'un peu moins de la moitié du dernier
décile de la distribution dans cette lo
finan initiale il est incontestable que
cette phrase est factuellement avérée
mieux si nous maintenons le gel du barê
dans son ensemble nous corrigeons ces
effets à l'entrée dans le barê et entre
la première et la deuxième tranche toute
chose égal par ailleurs aurait payé des
impôts 7,4 millions de foyers qui ne
paieront pas davantage d'impôts par
rapport à 2012 grâce à un mécanisme de
décotte que nous instaurons et à
l'entrée dans la première tranche et
entre la première et la deè tranche donc
oui les ménages qui sont sollicités sont
ceux qui le peuvent le plus c'est-à-dire
dans la deuxème partie du deuxème décile
de la distribution l'effort est
difficile à partir de 15000 € par mois
il est rude à partir de 40000 € par mois
mais c'est bien cela à qui nous
demandons de consentir cet effort et ce
faisant nous pensons préserver la
croissance car c'est ge là pour autant
qu'ils concèdeent cet effort ne
compromettront pas ne diminueront pas
leur capacité de consommation et l' a
veill ne pas diminuer cette capacité de
consommation car vous le savez la
consommation est la contrepartie pour
près des 2/3 de la croissance économique
dans notre pays deuxème volet la
fiscalité les entreprises avec le même
souci de ne pas solliciter des
entreprises et se faisant de
compromettre les capacités
d'investissement de nos entreprises
raison pour laquelle ce sont
principalement les grands groupes qui
sont sollicités c'est vrai avec pour
l'essentiel deux mesures d'abord
une fin mise à la déductibilité
intégrale des intérêts d'empin pour les
entreprises 15 % en moins cette année 25
% à terme ne pourront plus être déduits
de l'assiette à l'impôt sur les sociétés
cette mesure est forte elle permet un
rendement l'année prochaine de 4
milliards d'euros et puis la deuxième
mesure symbolique est une correction de
ce qu'on a appelé la niche Copé
en injustifié c'est la niche mar
vous savez l'usage parfois l'emporte sur
l'histoire enfin je suis sûr que vous
saurit faire ce qu'il faut pour libérer
monsieur Copé de de ce poids
probablement difficile à supporter
puisque vous vous proposez de l'alléger
vous-même quoi qu'il en soit la la la D
la niche dite Copé abusément mais en
vérité Marini cette niche là sera en
partie réduite l'année prochaine de 2
milliards d'euros en tenant compte non
plus des plus-values nettes mais des
plusvalues brutes pour arriver à ce
rendement-l d'autres mesures sont
également proposées que que que le cas
échéant vous pourriez citer en en
espérant des précisions soit de la part
de Pierre mcovici soit de ma part ce
sera évidemment bien volontiers voilà à
gros trait monsieur le Président vous m'
aviez engagé présenter le le budget pour
2013 30 milliards 10 milliards
d'économie 10 milliards de fiscalité
ménage concentré sur les revenus les
plus aisés 10 milliards de fiscalité
entreprise concentré
sur les plus grandes entreprises toutes
les dispositions fiscales favorables aux
PME sont conservées mieux le crédit
impôt recherche innovation est élargi de
300 millions d'euros pour ces
entreprises là je pense que c'est une
disposition qui ne devrait pas
rencontrer d'obstacle majeurs au sein de
votre assemblée voilà Monsieur le le
président en espérant ne pas avoir été
trop elliptique sur certaines
dispositions mais le cas échant je suis
sûr que vous saurez nous ramener à plus
de précision si vous le jugez nécessaire
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
délégué d'avoir bien V voulu vous prêter
à cet exercice donc c'est une
introduction au débat pour le ministre
de l'économie et des finances nous
étions convenus avec Jérôme Cusac qui
lançait le débat par un exposé
volontairement bref et nous étions donc
convenus qu'à l'aide des questions et
nous pourrions
approfondir les différents aspects de ce
budget alors je sauf si vous souhaitez
faire une déclaration liminaire alors je
me tourne vers le rapporteur général
François Marc en lui demandant de bien
vouloir lancer les les les premières
questions puisque depuis vendredi il a
épluché les documents
budgétaires merci monsieur le
Président remercie les ministres d'être
avec nous je remercie Jérôme kisac de
l'exposé qui vient de nous faire d'une
façon très synthétique mais nous avions
en tête un certain nombre d'orientations
d'autant que ces orientations il a dit
lui-même sont en li Lig avec les
promesses du candidat aujourd'hui
président de la République et qui avait
annoncé sa volonté de d'en arriver à ce
cet assaainissement ce redressement des
finances
publiques et bien entendu tout ceci est
de nature à
consolider
toute la crédibilité la signature de la
France faut se féliciter aussi que le
gouvernement n'attende pas d'être revenu
à meilleur forortune budgétaire pour
engager d'ors et déjà des réformes
structurelles de notre fiscalité
autrement dit c'est bien de thématique
de l'effort juste dont nous avons
aujourd'hui à débattre ou du
redressement dans la justice comme
disait notre président lorsqu'il était
candidat et nous avons bien noté
messieurs les ministres que l'adoption
conjointe en conseil des ministres du
PLF pour 2013 et de la loi de
programmation
2013-207 montre s'il en était besoin que
le PLF 2013 doit être analysé dans le
cadre d'une d'une stratégie globale des
finances publiques c'est pourquoi je
commencerai par quelques questions sur
ce sujet de la programmation des
finances publiques et tout d'abord
peut-être pourriez-vous nous repréciser
les choses en ce qui concerne les
chiffres et les montants qui sont
évoqués parce que s'agissant de de ces
chiffres on a parfois un peu de mal à
s'y retrouver puisque le déficit de
l'État va se réduire de de 20 20
milliards le déficit des administrations
publiques doit se rédire de 30
milliards et le gouvernement a a
communiqué donc sur un effort de 30
milliards mais monsieur le ministre de
l'Économie nous a indiqué que il fallait
plutôt se fi à 37 milliards puisque
s'ajoute au 30 milliards les effets des
mesure déjà voté en juillet quant à
lesffs structurels il conduit à faire
état de 40 milliards plus de 37
40 par ailleurs le rapport annexé au
projet de loi de finances parle l'uneff
sur les dépenses de 03 points de
PIB soit 6 milliards d'euros et non 10
comme l'avait retenu la communication du
gouvernement bref il y a je crois sur
les chiffres de trois précisions qui les
sont opportuns de nous redonner ici euh
puisque euh il est important de de
préciser à la fois les montants et
comment les efforts supplémentaires sont
répartis entre catégories
d'administration publique et entre
recettes et
dépenses s'agissant de
euh de la croissance
plus
particulièrement du TSCG et de la future
loi organique nous avons bien compris
que aujourd'hui dans l'évolution des
choses des toutes prochaines années on
peut être amené à corriger les
dispositions adoptées si des
circonstances exceptionnelles comme il
est dit dans euh ce euh projet de de
texte euh sont constatés alors
euh peut-on mieux expliciter euh ce
terme de circonstance exceptionnelle et
euh en quoi euh des périodes de grave
récession économique peuvent être cerné
d'une façon un peu plus précise en
d'autres termes si la croissance était
de - 05 % en 2013 est-ce qu'on pourrait
considérer qu'on est dans cette
situation telle que précisé dans le TSCG
de grave récession économique c'est une
question peut-être qui permettrait de de
mieux éclairer les choses j'en viens au
collectivité territoriale puisque bien
sûr au Sénat c'est un sujet qui nous
tient à cœur et euh il est indiqué dans
l'article 8 que les collectivités
territoriales contribueront à l'effort
de redressement des finances publiques
je cite selon des modalités à
l'élaboration d'écoes elles sont
associées donc la question est posée de
savoir et serion heureux d'avoir
quelques précisions sur ces modalités
quelle est la signific
concrète de la formulation qui est qui
est ainsi
développée alors s'agissant enfin des
dotations de l'enveloppe on sait
que il y aurait peut-être des évolutions
différenciées selon les niveaux de
collectivité puisque le rapport de la
Cour des comptes indiquait bien que les
différentes catégories de collectivité
ne sont pas dans des situations
équivalentes relativement à leur
situation financière donc est-ce qu'on
peut imaginer que l'effort de5 milliards
soit réparti entre ces différents
niveaux d'une
façon spécifique à chacun des niveaux
c'est là aussi une question peut-être
sur laquelle des précisions pourrait
être déjà apporté alors s'agissant du
projet de loi de finance strict au sensu
pour 2013 j'évoquerai en premier lieu le
le MES le Mécanisme Européen de
Stabilité puisque à l'intention de de
mes collègues je je fais remarquer que
le PLF prévoit pour 6,5 milliards
d'euros de versement des 3e et 4e
tranche de versement en capital au MES
lequel on le sait va devenir
opérationnel le 8 octobre c'est-à-dire
lundi
prochain peut-être que le ministre de
l'économie pourrait nous indiquer
comment se passent les derniers
préparatifs avant la mise à feu de ce
dispositif dans tous les T prochains t
les les tous prochains jours
pardon une autre question porte sur les
plusvalu de cession puisque aujourd'hui
on peut s'interroger sur les
impacts de cette fiscalisation au barê
des des
plusvalidesessions s'agissant des
transmissions d'entreprise et donc des
réinvestissements est-il légitime de
fiscaliser de la même façon tous les cas
de figure à savoir les plusvalues rés de
la gestion de portefeuille pour un petit
actionnaire ou euh la plus-value d'un
chef d'entreprise qui vend sa société
dont le revenu de l'année suivante est
ainsi gonflé donc il y a une question là
qui se pose sur l'étendue de ce
dispositif et sur les incidences qu'il
peut avoir selon les cas de figure et
j'imagine que il y a peut-être lieu
d'examiner un débat parlementair C ces
différents cas les uns par rapport aux
autres alors sagit issant
de l'abattement de 40 % sur les
dividendes peut-être il y a-t-il
quelques éléments nouveaux puisque le
Conseil pray obligatoire avait considéré
que le principe d'un abonnement était
justifié pour éviter que le dividende
soit taxé à la fois à l'IS et à
l'IER mais le CPO n'était pas parvenu à
déterminer le bon niveau donc peut-être
qu'il a des éléments nouveaux puisque on
a aujourd'hui avancé au niveau du du
projet de loi de finances et peut-être
pourrions-nous éclairer sur ce
point alors j'en viens à mes deux
derniers sujets de préoccupation le
premier sur les valeurs locatives
foncières nous avons adopté dans le
projet de loi de finance rectificative
la mise en œuvre d'un
dispositif de révision généralisée des
valeurs locatives professionnelles euh
donc euh les choses ont-elles été euh
programmées peut-être pourriz-vous nous
indiquer comment les les choses sont
envisagées pour la mise en œuvre de ce
dispositif qui devrait être opérationnel
en tout état de cause au 1er janvier
2015 donc pourriez-vous nous nous donner
des indications sur la mise en œuvre et
sur les perspectives ultérieur
s'agissant par exemple des locaux
d'habitation peut-être avez-vous déjà
quelques indications à nous donner sur
les orientations à mettre en œuvre enfin
un dernier sujet euh celui de la masse
salariale la masse salariale euh par
rapport à la précédente législature où
la suppression de 30000 postes n'avait
permis qu'une légère diminution de la
masse serire en
2012 nous constatons ici que la masse
ser nugmentera que de 80,4 à 80,6
milliards d'euros respectant ainsi un
engagement du chef de l'État donc est-ce
que vous pourriez nous donner des
précisions sur ce maintien en quelque
sorte de de de la masse salariale et et
nous donner des des assurances
concernant ce ce chiffrage c'est un
point d'éclairage
qui serait fort agréable aussi de de
voir préciser aujourd'hui voilà monsieur
le Président quelquesunes des questions
il y en a bien d'autres mais je crois
qu'il faut se limiter le temps est
compté et si sur ces points on peut
avoir des éclairages je crois que nos
collègues des arguments pour leur propre
réflexion des des semaines à venir sur
ce budget merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur général je partage tout à
fait vos questions permettez-moi
messieurs les ministres d'en
ajouter une une brève liste et
commençons par les économies budgétaires
et la question qui me semble-t-il se
pose est celle de la documentation de
ces
économies en allant plus avant dans le
projet de loi de finance nous y verrons
naturellement plus
clair jusqu'ici à ma connaissance seule
la ministre de la Culture a détaillé de
manière précise ce qui est
méritoire les
opérations qui devrai être interrompu
les conséquences concrètes sur le budget
de sa mission la crainte que je me
permets d'exprimer porte sur les règles
qui sont annoncées en matière
d'évolution par nature de dépenses
lorsqu'on dit moins temp % sur le
fonctionnement moins temp% sur les
crédits d'intervention pourriez-vous par
exemple s'agissant des interventions
nous dire les dispositifs qui seraiit
touché ou
freiné toujours dans ce domaine des
économies
et en me souvenant des des
appréciations des appréciations assez
négative pour rester dans la litote qui
était porté sur la revue générale des
politiques publiques la
RGPP qualifié de non intelligente
et j'aurais souhaité savoir si ce
processus
d'économie se traduit bien par un
réexamen de certaines fonction de l'état
car nous savons que pour des ordres de
grandeur aussi importants il est
difficile d'en rester à un
échenillage de tout crédit mais des
choix sont nécessaires des choix
fonctionnels des réformes au sein de
l'administration j'avais cru comprendre
qu'un premier rendu des ministres était
attendu pour fin septembre sur ce thème
fin septembre étant maintenant derrière
nous peut-être pourriez-vous nous en
dire plus je VI à la fiscalité si vous
le voulez bien et et je m'associe à la
question de François Marc sur la
taxation au barê pour les plus-values
non récurrentes il a cité les
transmissions
d'entreprise et je pense qu'il y a là
effectivement un problème qui se pose
lorsque la plus-value rémunère un risque
assumé pendant une longue période par un
agent économique je m oge bien sûr vous
vous en doutez sur les conséquences des
mesures prises en matière de taxation
des revenus patrimoniaux et je serais
surpris que cette
taxation ne soit pas
douloureuse
pour une fraction appréciable des
contribuables de conditions moyennes les
contribuables par exemple taxés au taux
marginal de 30
% me semble-t-il devrait plutôt figurer
parmi les perdants
pourriez-vous revenir sur ce point et et
et et me dire quel est votre
appréciation de la question en matière
de de d'ISF j'observe
d'ailleurs avec
avec un sentiment positif le
rétablissement d'un plafonnement de cet
impôt au taux de 75 % des revenus du
contribuable je serais tenté de vous
poser la question de la différence de
nature entre ce plafonnement et euh l'ex
bouclier fiscal tant Oni et tant
vilipandet est-ce que cela ne relève pas
euh de raisonnement euh voisins
et vous
euh pouvez effectivement penser que
plusieurs d'entre nous vous
interrogeront sur les dépenses locales
les efforts demandés aux collectivités
territoriales et est-il en particulier
euh prévu euh de tenir compte des
dépenses euh liées aux allocations de
solidarité dont les départements ont la
charge euh évolutions sur lesquelles ils
n'exerce pas de choix et qui ces
dernières années euh suscitaent euh euh
dans notre hémicycle des des des
interventions euh tout à fait euh euh
tout à fait passionné donc
comment gérer ce squeeze entre des des
des des des des ressources stables et
des allocations des dépenses de guichet
qui évoluent à un tautx élevé parce
qu'il s'agit de droits qui sont exercés
par nos concitoyens enfin sur les
entreprises il me semble que la mesure
la plus structurante est celle
qui met fin à la
déductibilité totale des charges
financières et quant à l'impôt sur les
sociétés parfois on invoque l'exemple
allemand en ce
domaine j'ai revu ce sujet et je
rappelle qu'en Allemagne avant de
procéder à cette mesure il a été décidé
une diminution du taux de la impôt sur
les sociétés car s'agissant de notre
pays une limitation à 75 % de la
déductibilité ce qui s'appliquera à
partir de
2014 cela reviendrait pour les
entreprises les plus importante à taxer
un/4 de leur charg financière au taux de
36 %. alors je me pose la question de
l'impact conjoncturel alors que la
croissance est si faible voir alors que
nous sommes menacés euh
par une pure stagnation de l'activité en
2013 est-il vraiment opportun de
pénaliser de manière significative des
investissements financés sur le
marché des opérations de croissance
externe eu est-ce que cette mesure n'est
pas susceptible de de de créer
enfin d'avoir des conséquences
dépressives sur l'activité le rythme des
affaires voilà messieurs les ministres
une sélection de quelques questions bon
reviendront sur tout cela bien entendu
je pense que beaucoup de nos collègues
vont revenir sur ces sujets et aborder
bien d'autres sujet mais
pourriez-vous répondre au rapporteur
général et et me répondre sur ces
quelques aspects avant que la discussion
générale ne
s'engage
bien je vais commencer par répondre en
vous vous priant de pardonner mon mon
retard je suis très heureux de
participer ici à la discussion sur ce
projet de budget pour 2013 que je
considère comme un bon budget marqué par
par trois mots d'abord le redressement
qui était indispensable nécessaire dès
lors que nous sommes dans une situation
de de déficit qui ne pouvait pas être
tenu plus longtemps le D ement est une
condition de la compétitivité et nous ne
voulons pas et je ne veux pas d'une
France qui se trouverait parce que elle
reste endettée parce qu'elle a des
déficits trop élevés livré pieds et
pointliés aux mains des marchés avec les
effets que nous connaissons dans
d'autres économies et chacun connaît les
chiffres ici un point de taux d'intérêt
en plus c'est 2 milliards sur un an
c'est 14 milliards si on se met sur 10
ans et et en plus on sait que quand on
commence par en avoir un on en a plus
c'est les effets boule de neige que
d'autres pays ont ont connu et nous
voulons absolument les épargner au pays
en même temps c'est Jérôme a dû le dire
un budget de justice donc qui épargne
les couches populaires les couches
moyennes les petites et moyennes
entreprises et du coup un budget
d'efficacité économique parce que
précisément les capacités à consommer
les capacités à investir sont préservées
au questions de François Marc je je vais
en prendre quelquesunes on va se
compléter avec Jérôme maintenant déjà
des exercices communs que nous allons
faire devant vous avec grand plaisir et
complémentaire je reviendrai sur les
questions qu'il a posé au sujet du
projet de loi organique qui découle du
TSCG qui est en ce moment même en cours
d'examen devant l'Assemblée nationale et
qui viendra bien sûr devant vous pour
dire que ce projet de loi organique
n'est pas un carcan de lequel on va
enserrer les dépenses publiques celle de
l'État celle des organismes de sécurité
sociale celle des collectivités locales
mais qu'il est c'est sa nature même
d'ailleurs un ensemble de règles de
procédures de règles du jeu qui sont
nécessaires pour mieux piloter nos
finances publiques et les piloter à
partir de la notion de déficit
structurel c'est-à-dire déficit corrigés
des aléas eu même liés à la conjoncture
le Conseil constitutionnel a dit les
choses comme elles devaient être dites
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y avait pas
nécessité d'inscrire une règle d'or pas
de nécessité de l'inscrire dans la
Constitution pas d'atteinte à la
souveraineté et qu'il s'agissait plutôt
de voir comment on pouvait codifier le
retour à l'équilibre des finances
publiques qui le Conseil constitutionnel
l'a rappelé fait partie des objectifs
édictés à l'article 34 de notre
Constitution c'est de ça dont il s'agit
et dès lors dans la rédaction que nous
avons piloté et qui vous sera soumise je
crois qu'on va trouver un un équilibre
euh avec à la fois cette définition des
objectifs en matière de solde structurel
la création d'un Haut Conseil des
finances publiques qui euh est composé
pour partie de magistrat de la Cour des
comptes pour partie de membres désignés
par les présidents des assemblées et des
commissions des finances des deux
assemblées donc qui respectent la
souveraineté parlementaire qui écoute le
Parlement et enfin euh des mécanismes de
correction des écarts et c'est dans ce
contexte-là qu'arrive la notion de
circonstances exceptionnelles
qu'évoquait France remarque alors
s'agissant de cette notion
euh il est dit qui compris en cas de
circonstances exceptionnelle y compris
récession grave il y a possibilité de
s'écarter temporairement de l'objectif
de moyen terme ou des trajectoires
d'ajustement la loi organique se réfère
précisément à la définition qui est
celle du traité qui va vous être soumis
disant que par circonstance
exceptionnelle il faut entendre c'est
définition de circonstances
exceptionnell des fait inhabituels
indépendant de la volonté de la partie
contractante et ayant des effets
sensibles sur la situation financière
desadministration publique ou à des
périodes je cite de grave récession
économique c'est bien de ça dont il
s'agit et c'est assez dire que à la fois
à travers ces circonstances
exceptionnelles et à travers le passage
à la notion de déficit structurel on
conserve des capacités à piloter les
finances publiques avec des capacités
contracycliques ce qui est je crois
beaucoup plus avantageux et beaucoup
plus intelligent surtout que un pilotage
qui se résumerait au au au seul chiffres
nominaux étant entendu je le précise que
c'est bien 3 % en nominal que nous
visons pour 2013 qui est un objectif
auquel nous tenons et sur lequel nous
tiendrons euh enfin ayant dit ça j'ai
j'ai donné la définition à François Mar
je vou dire que heureusement nous n'y
sommes pas aujourd'hui à ces
circonstances exceptionnelles euh nous
ne sommes pas en récession et je vous
rappel que la France résiste mieux que
beaucoup d'autres qu'elle reste dans le
Ploton de tête d'un Ploton qui certes
avance trop lentement beaucoup trop
lentement euh mais ce dispositif nous
permettra à l'avenir d'apprécier de
manière concertée si nous sommes en
circonstances exceptionnelles donc c'est
une arme qui est entre les mains de
l'ensemble du dispositif de finances
publiqu et donc entre les mains du
Parlement Infiné puisque c'est ainsi que
les choses se définissaient et j'ai dit
au passage s'agissant des collectivités
locales que évidemment elle ne pouvait
pas être hors du cadre qui est le cadre
de pilotage des finances publiques mais
que aucune formulation humiliante ou qui
reviendrait sur la libre administration
des collectivités locales qui est un
principe auquel nous sommes attachés ne
peut être prise mais en même temps c'est
logique puisqu'il s'agit d'une loi
organique donc il n'y a là rien qui soit
contraire à ce que nous souhaitons sur
les 37 milliards que j'ai pu à un moment
donné évoquer Jérôme Cusac a précisé de
quoi il s'agissait je le redis ces 30
milliards annoncés par la programmation
qui est contenue dans le PLF et dans le
PLFSS plus 4,5 milliards d'euros d'ffet
en année pleine de la LFR plus 2,7
milliards d'économie sur
lâ vous avez demandé des des précisions
sur un certain nombre de chiffres je
crois qu'il faut bien distinguer
l'effort en dépense mesuré en prenant
pour référence la croissance potentielle
euh et les économies que nous prenons en
prenant pour référence la tendance
spontanée des dépenses qui elle est
supérieure à la croissance potentielle
c'est là on voit d'ailleurs que nous ne
sommes pas encore tout à fait au
raisonnement déficit structurel
autrement dit l'effort en dépense c'est
technique par rapport à la croissance
potentielle et bien de 03 points c'est 6
milliards et les économies par rapport à
la dépense tendentielle sont bien de 10
milliards d'euros ce qui me permet au
passage de dire au au président
Marini
que il y aura au fur et à mesure la
discussion budgétaire comme vous l'avez
demandé une documentation des économies
mais qu'on ne s'y trompe pas ces
économies ne sont ni fictive ni
mineur l'effort budgétaire en en 2013 ce
sera 10 milliards d'euros et il n'y a
pas question qu'il y ait la moindre
esquive sur ce sujet-là ça veut dire
qu'en 2013 la masse salariale globale et
les dépenses en volume de l'État seront
stable ça veut dire que la baisse des
crédits de fonctionnement concernera
tous les ministères avec une économie
moyenne de 5 % le PLF proposera une
économie de 2 % sur les dotations aux
opérateurs de l'État les collectivités
locales seront également associé au
redressement au travers d'une
stabilisation de leur dotation il y a
donc un effort net et moi je pense qu'il
faut le revendiquer les Français dans
cette situation de redressement attendre
en effet que les collectivités publiques
participent à cela mais simplement cet
effort il est maîtrisé il n'est pas un
effort d'austérité puisque nous ne
coupons pas sur les salaires nous ne
revenons pas sur les grands équilibres
de notre modèle social ou notre re
système de protection sociale et il
respecte aussi un certain nombre de
priorités qui vous sont présentées
l'éducation la sécurité la justice pour
l'emploi l'emploi de manière générale
François Marc aussi interrogé sur les
plus-value de session on a entendu les
les remous qui ont été suscités par la
mise au barê des plus-valu qui
pourtant partie intégrante de la réforme
fiscale de justice que nous proposons
pour mémoire les les revenus des 1000
Français les plus riches sont composés à
78 % de plusvalue et pour autant dans le
texte que nous proposons il faut bien
voir un certain nombre de mesures
d'atténuation que je reprécise un
système de lissage qui sera mis en place
qui serait mis en place il est voté pour
tenir compte du caractère pluriannuel de
la plusvalue lors de la première année
d'application du barem deuxièmement pour
les sessions à compté de 2013 un
dispositif
d'incitation à la détention longue avec
des abattement et est prévu enfin nous
ne revenons pas sur les exonérations
pour départ la retraite d'une part et
pour réinvestissement dans une
entreprise d' d'utre part je rappelle
également que les plus-values des jeunes
entreprises innovantes sont exonérées je
profite d'ailleurs de de ce moment pour
dire que nous serons très attentif dans
la discussion à tout ce qui concernera
les start-ups les entreprises qui
innovent il faudra que la discussion
permette peut-être d'avancer sur ce
point-là euh mais c'est ce qui se
déroulera dans les temps qui viennent
voilà les quelques éléments sur lesquels
pour ma part je souhaitais revenirant à
Jérôme Cusac le soin de de
compléter monsieur le ministre délégué
merci Monsieur le le président euh à
François Marc qui s'interrogait sur
leseff de collectivité locale je l'ai
présenté au Comité des finances locales
la semaine dernière donc 1,5 milliards
d'euros sur
2014-25 un effort à comparer au 60
milliards de l'enveloppe normée au 100
milliards de concours de l'État au 220
milliards de budget des collectivités
locales en vérité je crois que CTA efft
et supportable d'autant qu'on laisse le
FCTV en dehors de cette enveloppe l'état
prenant sur lui si j'ose dire cet effort
consenti en faveur des collectivités car
dès lors que cette dépense est en
principe dans la norme zéro valeur si
cette zéro valeur ne s'applique pas aux
collectivité c'est que notre structure
resp l'état l'assume pour son compte oui
bien sûr c'est un remboursement mais
pour avoir entendu souvent jean-Pierre
Fourcade il a longtemps siégé ici dire
ce qui avait présidé la restauration du
FCTVA peut-être pourrait-on au moins
entre nous être plusancé sur la nature
réelle de cette dotation là euh pour
maintenz la pratique précédente comment
vous maintenez la pratique de vos
prédécesseurs à ceci prè qu'elle ne
s'est pas elle n'était pas celle-là une
ou deux années non pas en 2011 mais il
me semble enre 2009 et 2010 le FC TVA
avait été mis sous l'enveloppe au moins
une année j'en suis à peu près certain
probablement deux l'année dernière
cétait dernière nous sommes 1 fois
d'accord donc nous maintenons la
pratique de l'année dernière à défaut de
revenir à celle qui avait présidé les de
années auparavant je crois bien euh sur
les les exemples d'économie parce que je
je crois qu'effectivement il faut
rentrer un peu dans le détail des choses
il y aura une suppression du dispositif
d'exonération de charge pour
travailleurs salariés permanent dans
l'agriculture c'est d'ailleurs un
dispositif qui va être condamné à
Bruxelles donc cette économie est
obligatoire il y aura un recentrage du
FISAC sur les zones prioritaires il y
aura une baisse des subventions
certaines associations sportives c'est
regrettable mais il faut faire des
efforts il y aura par exemple une
suppression de l'indemnité de résidence
versé au consortium Stade de France il y
aura un alignement du régime des
auto-entrepreneurs sur celui des
commerçants et artisans encore que les
auto-entrepreneurs gardent leur facilité
déclarative ne paient pas de cotisation
minimale en cas de chiffre d'affaires
nul mais voit leur cotisation alléigné
sur celle des artisans et commerçants
qui en vérité exercent le même métier
mais de manière beaucoup plus
réglementée voilà quelques exemples
d'économie sur l'ISF je voudrais
répondre au président Marini il y a
quand même plusieurs différences par
rapport à ce que vous appelez vous-même
le bouclier fiscal d'abord le taux 50 %
ça n'est pas 75 % loin sen faut ensuite
la nature peut-être vous souvenez-vous
que le bouclier comprenait les impôts
locaux ce qui n'est pas le cas les
plafonnement que nous proposons
d'instaurer ensuite les modalités de
calcul de ce plafonnement euh prendront
en compte les revenus capitalisés et
dans certains cas des plus-values
latentees afin d'éviter l'optimisation
de ce plafonnement par un pilotage euh
du revenu comme précisément on avait pu
le constater euh lorsque le bouclier
fiscal avait euh force de loi donc je
crois qu'il y a des différences de
nature assez sensibles entre ce
plafonnement à 75 % et ce que vous
appelez vous-même ce que nous appelons
nous-mêmes ensemble et et désormais le
bouclier fiscal à 50
%.
euh sur euh la déducbilé d'intérêts
d'emprunt vous avez effectivement fait
référence à l'Allemagne le dispositif
français plutôt moins dur que dispositif
allemand qui euh empêche de déduire 30 %
de l'bidda c'est une mesure qui nous a
paru beaucoup trop procyclique pour être
revenu tel quel et donc seul 15 % des
intérêts financiers euh ne seront plus
déductibles quand en Allemagne ce
pourcentage peut-être beaucoup plus
important et naturellement beaucoup plus
procyclique on s'est inspiré de l'idée
sans aller euh jusqu'à cette disposition
toute
germanique sur les valeurs locatives il
n'y a pas dans la loi de financeces
initiale monsieur rapporteur général de
disposition qui soit prévu à cet effet
nous verrons à l'occasion de du débat ce
qu'il en est et je pense que pour les
autres questions Pierre Moscovici avait
me semble-t-il répondu à celle que vous
aviez pu poser et bien merci messieurs
les ministres donc nous allons passer
aux questions de nos différents
collègues alors le premier à avoir levé
la main tout à l'heure si je ne me
trompe était Richard
Jung merci monsieur le Président ma
question porte sur le
l'aspect de la de la croissance on
connaît l'hypothèse de croissance et on
sait que un ensemble de mesures
importantes ont été adoptées au sommet
européen de fin juin
dernier redéploiement des fonds
européens non
utilisés augmentation de capital de la
BEI création des project bonds des des
bon de
projet et la la TTF alors ma ma première
question c'est pouvez-vous nous nous
dire où on en est dans la mise en œuvre
de ce dispositif européen et quel
comment vous vous mesurez ou comment
vous évaluez les effets positif bien sûr
que nous espérons qu'il aura
sur le budget 2000 2013 et deuxè partie
de la
question vous venez d'écrire je crois
ensemble avec Monsieur
chauble à vos collègues ministrees des
finances de de la zone euro pour les
encour
à venir vers le projet de de TTF est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire un petit peu
plus sur cette sur cette lettre et
est-ce que vous avez
déjà du
feedback merci la parole est à Emer de
montesquieou merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre du Budget chacun écouté ave
beaucoup d'intérêt votre exposé tout à
fait clair mais j'ai deux points qui qui
me pose interrogation vous avez dit que
les économies étaient plus
récessives que les impôts euh vous
semblez oublier l'aspect incitatif des
résultats nets pour les entreprises et
des revenus pour les ménages vous avez
qui était très difficile de faire
plus vous avez dit qu'il était très
difficile de faire plus d'économie or
avec 57 % de dépenses publiques nous
sommes second pays je crois au niveau
européen pourquoi est-ce qu'on ne peut
pas se mettre euh à la moyenne
européenne je rappelle par exemple que
pour 1000 habitants il y a deux fois
plus de fonctionnaires en France qu'en
RFA vous avez abordé le problème des
surplus et j'aimerais parler des surplus
pour ce qui est du CNC euh pararticle 28
euh vous
dispenser le CNC du plafond
euh euh
qui atteint tout tous les autres
organismes et vous prélevez 150 millions
sur leur 800 millions de
trésoreries il me semble monsieur le
ministre que quelquefois vous avez la
main plus lourde il n'y a aucune raison
qu'un organisme puisse ainsi tésoriser
enfin je suis un peu surpris que le
CNC qui dispose donc de ce cette
cagnotte de 8 million est emprunté pour
acheter un immeuble dans Paris le CNC
possède qu immeubles tous dans le 16e il
refuse d'être Paris extramurau ça me
semble tout à fait contradictoire avec
la politique de
rationnellement immobilière que vous
souhaitez
mener à EM montesc qui anticipe un peu
mais il en a bien le droit comme
corapporteur spécial de la culture sur
l'audition de demain matin sur le Centre
national de la
cinématographie alors j'ai le plaisir de
passer la parole à Gérard mckel
oui merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres moi je voudrais
saluer l'effort que vous avez fait en
matière de justice fiscale en
effet l'impô sera plus justement
réparti et avec la décôte que vous
appliquez sur les deux premières
tranches je l'IMP sur le revenu euh je
crois que les les les Français
comprendront que vous faites pr vous
prélevez l'impôt de façon beaucoup plus
équitable mais je voudrais vous demander
votre avis sur un point car nous avons
un certain nombre de nos concitoyens un
grand nombre de concitoyens qui ne
paient pas d'impôt sur le revenu et
quand ils viennent nous voir dans nos
permanences ils nous amènent leur
feuille d'impôt
local et ils nous disent on peut plus
les payer ces impôts parce qu'ils sont
trop lourds nous avons essayé d'engager
depuis longtemps une réforme des bases
de la fiscalité
locale et nous n'échapperons pas à une
révision de ces bases si nous voulons
mettre un peu de justice dans dans cet
impôt local en particulier cet impôt
local qui est prélevé par les
communautés de communes les conseils
généraux sur des bases qui sont très
inégales et très injustes alors est-ce
que vous envisagez monsieur le ministre
de d'engager une réforme de ses bases je
sais que François Marc a beaucoup
travaillé sur ce sujet avec pierre
Jarlier il me semble que ce serait
nécessaire al merci à Gérard miel qui
revient sur un
sujet c'est un sujet de long terme ça
bon François patria demander la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi j'aiéci
aussi présentation qui a été faite par
les ministres beaucoup de questions ont
été posées par vous-même et par notre
rapporteur c'est vrai que ce budget
qu'on peut considérer que comme
courageux est un budget de
rupture mais aussi un budget qui répond
à la préconisation du FMI qui a été
faite au début de l'été disant que si on
doit remettre de l'ordre dans les
finances publiques il vaut mieux pour
gagner la confiance des marchés et des
financeurs il vaut mieux le faire
progressivement que brutalement donc pas
de brutalité mais seulement des mesures
fortes dans un contexte triplement
difficile celui de la conjoncture qu'on
connaît en second lieu celui de la mise
en œuvre ces
semaines-ci des ce que nous avons décidé
dans la loi de finance rectificative en
juillet et qui apparaît pour beaucoup de
Français aujourd'hui et puis en 3è lieu
la période de l'année
où apparaissent en effet comme la dit
Gérard Michel les impôts locaux qui
pèsent lourdement et donc parfois on a
pas relever la hausse qui a été parfois
importante alors dans ce budget j'ai
bien noté que vous avez évoqué les
priorité monsieurs les ministres il y en
a une que vous n'avez pas cité pourtant
que j'ai retrouvé moi en regardant le
projet c'est que vous avez maintenu un
niveau élevé le budget de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche et ça je pense
que c'est une un effort à saluer parce
que des craintes avaient été porté ce
domaine autant je ne pense qu'il faut
pas tout le temps augmenter dépenses les
dépenses générales autant celle-là me
paraissait aussi prioritaire que que
d'autres qui ont été qui ont été
évoqués concernant les collectivités
locales alors j'ai bien entendu 750
millions 750 millions et l'effort
demandé est de
2illard250 sur la période alors que je
pense que l'ancien gouvernement avait
prévu de faire porter sur les
collectivités un effort de 2 milliards
par an ce qui faisait 10 milliards sur
la période il n'empêche que les élus
locaux vont s'interroger sur la façon de
poursuivre leur leurs actions et de
mettre en place leurs
compétences quand on a dans une
collectivité locale c'est sur le
fonctionnement qu'on doit économiser
pour avoir de la marge brute pour
pouvoir maintenir l'investissement chose
soit CLA la tendance pour les
collectivités locales aujourd'hui qui
est de baisser d'abord l'investissement
et de ne pas pouvoir trop baisser le
fonctionnement c'est bien que le
fonctionnement c'est les dépenses
habituelles je pense pour les régions la
formation professionnelle les transports
des lycées et cetera donc comment
va-t-on faire pour que les collectivités
locales je parle bien s là pour moi pour
les régions comment vont-elles faire
demain pour assumer autant de
compétences voir des compétences
transféré qu'elles ont elles-mêm
réclamé réclamer et dans le même temps
et dans le même temps supporter une BAE
drastique je vous rassure les
collectivités locales prépare leur
budget aujourd'hui en tout cas concerne
et elles vont préparer elles aussi des
budgets où la rigueur elle ira encore à
une forme d'audace et de créativité mais
mais il faudra leur dire on peut pas
dégager ce budget des réformes qui sont
adjacentes celle de la réforme des
collectivités locales celle des finances
locales et de la Réforme fiscal que nous
allons faire donc il faudra dire aux
collectivités peut-être recentrez-vous
sur vos compétences ou peut-être demain
n'assumez plus telle ou telle
compéttences les retirer par la loi si
on veut arriver parce qu' là aussi dans
les collectivités il y a des efforts
importants à titre personnel je baisser
le budget de la région que je préside de
6 % cette année pour accompagner cet
effort et montrer que nous accompagnant
leseff de l'État mais vers les
collectivités il faudra dans dans les
semaines qui viennent donner des signes
de chemin pour le faire dernière
choseist c'est pas une question c'est
une proposition on sait que c'est un
budget courageux on sait que c'est un
budget de rupture il va demander des
efforts de pédagogie parce que vous
savez que le ressenti des des Français
c'est qu' augmente les impôts même ceux
pour qui n'augmente pas ils pensent
qu'ils augmentent pensent qu'ils
augmentent donc il vut bien marquer le
cap vers lequel on va bien dire quelles
sont les priorités bien dire où on fait
les efforts parce que c'est quand même
le premier budget je le dis à mes chers
collègues le précédent quinena a
commencé sa première année avec des
dépenses supplémentaires de 15 milliards
je crois que c'est vous les messieur
minist qui l'avez dit ce gouvernement
commence son premier budget avec des
économies de 10 milliards c'est pas
suffisamment souvent pour qu'on ne
puisse pas le le rappeler
ici sans doute chers collègues mais si
l'on revient sur ce type de
considération cela vient après une année
2011 où les économies ont été
significatives et où nos positions aux
uns et aux autres et nos propos publics
n'étaient pas strictement les mêmes
qu'aujourd'hui notamment de votre côté
donc chacun gère ses contradictions nous
sommes dans un monde complexe et bon
mieux vaut
effectivement mieux vaut effectivement
éviter de de de de trop interpréter les
périodes passées puisqu'elles sont
mortes les périodes passées alors
Vincent delay lui va nous parler de
l'avenir
certainement bien sûr alors pour ma part
moi je partage bien sûr l'objectif de de
3 % de de déficit qui est qui est un
objectif difficile à tenir pardon mais
je pense que on fait encore preuve de
trop d'optimisme dans ce budget au
niveau des prévisions de croissance je
l'ai dit déjà l'an dernier moi ça fait
qu'un an que je suis arrivé ici au Sénat
mais je pense que messieurs vous pêchez
encore par optimisme et pour moi c'est
pas une qualité de prévision budgétaire
pour moi la la prévision budgétaire
c'est d'abord de la prudence et
aujourd'hui c'est pas prudent de prévoir
0,8 % en 2013 de croissance et 2 % par
la suite je pense que on part sur des
hypothèses qui sont beaucoup trop
optimistes et qui du coup vont nous
mettre dans le mur ensuite sur la
réduction du déficit moi j'ai toujours
été partisan au moins de partager les
efforts entre les économies et les
impôts et je pense que là vous le faites
pas du tout alors à chaque fois en
juillet dernier vous nous avez dit les
économies c'est plus difficile ça a
moins d'impact à court terme là vous
nous dites à court terme c'est plus
récessif mais moi je pense qu'il faut
regarder à long terme et je pense que
les économies elles font des effets à
long terme et on sent pas du tout pour
l'instant de réformes structurelles qui
puissent permettre ces économie moi je
pense que des économies on peut en
trouver moi j'en avais trouvé l'an
dernier sur le budget de la culture
j'avais fait des propositions
d'amendement qui ont été refusé en
séance sur la Maison de l'histoire de
France y compris non mais je sais bien
mais ça m'amuse parce que moi je les ai
proposé l'an dernier en séance et elles
ont été refusées sur l'audiovisuel elles
ont été refusé par tous les bans de du
Sénat et et cette année on s'aperçoit
que c'est possible donc je suis un peu
surpris oui c'est c'est changements mais
l'an dernier la majorité était la même
excusez-moi la majorité au Sénat était
la même et la majorité a refusé ces
amendements donc moi je suis un petit
peu surpris qu'on dise que c'est pas
possible de faire des économies alors
qu'on en propose et qu'elles sont
refusées donc je crois qu'il faut aussi
des réformes structurelles je vois les
pensions de retraite qui augmentent de 3
milliards est-ce qu'on va va continuer
un milliard ensuite l'année suivante et
un milliard ensuite est-ce que on va
continuer des réformes structurelles sur
les retraites sur les collectivités
locales on a parlait à l'instant est-ce
qu'on va continuer à avoir autant de
structurees on veut préserver la région
on veut préserver les départements
renforcer les intercommunautés on veut
conserver les communes tout ça je l'ai
entendu moi très largement et on va
encore l'entendre dans les états
généraux et je pense que c'est pas le
Haut Conseil des territoires qui viendra
remettre de l'ordre là-dedans et si on
n'est pas courageux pour supprimer un
échelon et rapidement comme le font les
Italiens parce que les Italiens ils sont
en train de le faire avec un
gouvernement technique donc c'est
peut-être un gouvernement technique qu'
nous faudrait parce que si on a un
gouvernement politique on n'y arrive pas
donc il y a un moment donné où il faut
je pense aller vers des réformes
structurelles j'aimerais bien que vous
nous disiez lesquelles vous envisagez de
prendre pour l'instant je n'ai vu que
des créations d'emploi pratiquement bien
sûr dans l'éducation et ailleurs j'ai vu
un certain nombre d'augmentation de de
ressources mais j'attends en dehors de
la culture des vraies économies de
dépenses et des réformes structurelles
sur la fiscalité je pense que vous êtes
en train d'asphixier les entreprises et
très fortement et on va le ressentir y
compris d'ailleurs pour les pour les
entrepreneurs et je pense que l'objectif
de d'aligner la fiscalité du capital sur
le travail je pense que c'est un bon
objectif mais que vous l'appliquez
peut-être de façon un peu trop brutale
et trop rapide et que on va très vite
décourager des gens qui ont envie
d'investir donc voilà mais mes questions
elles sont autour de
cela
j'ai j'ai deux autres questions alors
sur l'Union européenne je vois que le
budget augmente de de 700 millions
d'euros est-ce que on va demander à
l'Union européenne de faire les mêmes
efforts que nous appliquons et que la
plupart des pays la pique parce que les
fonctionnaires européens sont pas les
moins bien payés les élus européens non
plus donc tout ça ça mérite quand même
des questions à mon avis au niveau
européen qu'on qu'on puisse se poser
parce que c'est des dépenses qui
s'imposent à nous mais est-ce qu'on va
continuer à les laisser augmenter et
dernière question sur le Grand Paris
c'est l'élu de la région parisienne qui
pose la question mais
cuid la dotation en capital d'un
milliard qui était prévu normalement
pour la Société du Grand Paris est-ce
que elle est effectivement complètement
remise en question est-ce que les taxes
qui qui sont prélevées depuis quelques
temps sur les contribuables franciliens
pour le Grand Paris est-ce que ces taxes
sont reversé à sociéé de Grand Paris ou
elles sont
conservé bon
voilà à Vincent del qui aborde une série
de sujet concret marie-fance beaufice à
présent merci monsieur le Président vous
prion de m'excuser d'être arrivé en
retard mais j'étais coincé dans le
RB ça arrive quand on utilise les
transports publics on a de temps à autre
les alléas non ce n'était pas une Griff
une greffe c'était des questions
techniques pourquoi vous voulez toujours
penser à la grève on sait bien que la
France n'est pas obligatoirement le pays
qui a le plus de grève loin sans faut et
depuis de plusieurs années euh bon ceci
étant je reviens au budget ce qui à mon
avis est un élément important bon vous
le savez je ne partage pas votre point
de vue sur le TSCG et la la loi
organique mais je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion d' d'en discuter
prochainement puisque le dossier va
venir ici au Sénat après l'Assemblée
nationale je crois que un collègue l'a
dit vous vous faites un un effort en
terme de fiscalité pour qu'elle soit
plus juste je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion
dans le cadre du débat de vous faire des
propositions pour aller plus loin dans
cette justice fiscale moi ma ma seule et
unique question c'est le rythme auquel
vous
voulez aller pour aboutir à un déficit
publ réduit et rythme qui est me
semble-t-il trop
rapide qui en en pesant de à la fois sur
l'état la sécurité sociale et les
collectivités territoriales
risque d'avoir des incidences sur les
capacités d'avoir une amélioration de la
croissance et donc enrayer complètement
la possibilité de de de redresser la
situation et de faire en sorte de ne pas
être en capacité sur le fond de de
sortir des griffes des exigences des
marchés financiers contrairement à ce
que vous le dites voilà ma
question merci à mariefance befice qui a
bien voulu être concise synthétique dans
sa question et la parole est à Fabienne
Keller oui merci monsieur le Président
si vous me l'autoriserez trois trois
questions dans les domaines différents
messieurs les ministres merci pour cette
présentation d'abord une question sur
l'impôt sur les sociétés qui fera après
une stabilité en 2011 et 2012 un bon en
avant de 12 milliards d'euros si j'en
crois la page 3 du document de synthèse
on a compris qu'il y avait 5 milliards
par anticipation de paiement mais il y a
aussi 40 milliards prévu grâce à la fin
de la déductibilité des intérêts 4
milliards oui 4 j'ai dis autre chose 4
milliards je voudrais ici m'inquiéter
j'ai cru comprendre mais en lecture
rapide que pour épargner les PME vous
utilisez un seuil de 3 million d'euros
de montant de charge d'intérêt comment
assurez-vous que les grosses PME qui
investissent dans de nouvelles
technologies notamment hein des grosses
PME industrielles seront préservées et
comment assurez-vous que cette mesure
aura le moindre effet sur les groupes
mondialisés dont on voit organiser
régulièrement les restructurations
financières pour optimiser hein la
localisation de des différentes charges
et les remontées de résultats pour les
localiser là où c'est les plus le plus
intéressant fiscalement deuxè question
comme mon collègue je voudrais
m'inquiéter de l'absence de vision d'une
stratégie et pardonnez-moi mais je vais
partager une passion qui est la
fiscalité écologique ce n'est pas la
tgpr et le l'accentuation du bonus malus
qui va constituer une vraie stratégie
dans le domaine
environnemental lors de la conférence
environnementale est apparu l'idée sur
la fiscalité écologique c'est-à-dire un
vrai signal prix pour essayer
d'infléchir la consommation d'énergie se
donner les moyens pour gérer la
transition énergétique d'un groupe de
travail devenu proposition européenne
dans la feuille de route affich il y a
10 jours est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner des indications sur votre volonté
ou non de d'vrer au moins à moyen terme
dans ce domaine de la fiscalité
environnementale sachant que le seul
vrai signal donné était un peu à
l'envers avec la baisse du prix de
l'essence à la fin du mois d'août enfin
dernière question extra
buudgétaire les universités
de de France sont financés grâce au
budget de l'université je me réjouis
qu'ils soit stabilisé
mais de plus en plus grâce au Grand
Emprunt aux investissements d'avenir
avec une somme de l'ordre de 20
milliards d'euros qui a été localisé sur
un compte secret au trésor et dont les
produits sont versés régulièrement aux
universités ces fonds pour l'instant
contrairement à d'autres fonds du grand
emprunt n'ont pas été transférés aux
opérateurs est-ce que a la réponse sera
breve si vous le voulez bien est-ce que
ces crédits sont totalement sanctuarisés
oui ou
non à Fabienne Keller la parole est à
Joë Bourdin
oui monsieur le Président monieur les
ministres j'ai deux questions une
question de d'évaluation une question de
de méthode la la question d'évaluation
elle est
celle-ci le budget prévoit un certain
nombre de de modifications des des
impositions bon sur les ménages sur les
entreprises est-ce qu'on a a estimé dans
dans un modèle économétrique j'en sais
rien les incidences que tout ceci
devraiit avoir en 19 en 2013 sur
l'épargne parce que l'épargne c'est
l'investissement or si la capacité
d'épargne est érodé est-ce qu'on a pas
là un problème disons d'équilibre pour
l'avenir dans dans un schéma de
croissance ça ça c'est ma première
question deuxième question c'est une
question de de méthode
question de méthode sur l'exécution
budgétaire ce budget il sera adopté je
sais pas dans quelle forme il sera
adopté ensuite le gouvernement va
l'exécuter des des dépenses ont été
inscrites mais en fonction d'un taux de
croissance dont il aé rappelé tout de
suite qu'il est de 08 % s est plus élevé
très bien et si probabilité qui n'est
quand même pas négligeable et si le taux
de croissance est inférieur à 08 est-ce
qu'il il y aura régulation des dépenses
c'est-à-dire est-ce que le gouvernement
éventuellement ajustera les dépenses en
fonction de la croissance prévisible à
court terme en 2013 voilà ma question ma
deuxè
question question tout à fait
essentielle la parole est à Alberic de
Montgolfier merci Monsieur président
monsieur le ministre une question sur
d'abord sur les niches fiscales
particuli puisque la Commission des fin
n'a jamais été très partisane de ces
niches et donc nous ne sommes pas du
tout choqués bien au contraire par la la
réduction du plafond des niches mais
quand même un étonnement puisque je me
réfère à un excellent rapport qui avait
été signé à l'époque par Gilles carz par
Jérôme Cahusac et par d'autres sur les
niches fiscales et dans ce rapport on
soulignait que sur les 20 contribuables
les plus élevés il y en avait certains
qui éludaient totalement leur paiement
de l'impôt et ça se faisait à 97 % grâce
à la niche Girardin donc celle-ci est
hors plafond alors pour quelle raison
euh
échapperit Gérardin d' donc voilà alors
pour quelle raison elle échappperit
alors que c'est une des
niches a un collègue qui me regarde
méchamment mais pour quelle raison elle
échapperait au plafonnement des niches
alors même qu'elle permet d'échapper à
l'impôt et où est la justice fiscale
dans ce cas-là et deuxème question ma
question porte sur le gel puis la baisse
des concours financiers au collectivité
locale là aussi à la rigur je ne suis
pas choqué mais une condition cette
condition c'est que
on n rajoute pas en permanence
concrètement une journée de scolarité de
plus une augmentation du taux de la CN
CRL une augmentation du côé la
cotisation du Centre national de la
fonction publique territoriale donc
est-ce que les ministres peuvent prendre
des engagements pour accepter d'examiner
avec bienveillance tous les amendements
qui viseraient à supprimer ces charges
nouvelles non compensées pour les
collectivité par exemple on avait baissé
l'année dernière le taux de cotisation
CNFPT C année on va le remonter alors
que c'est un un organisme qui a beaucoup
coup d'argent et qui a pu s'acheter un
siège magnifique donc pourquoi pas
baisser ou geler les
concours financiers collectivité mais
quels engagements en face de ne pas
mettre des charges nouvelles pour les
collectivités à alberériic de
Montgolfier à présent au nom du
département de l'esson qui est très bien
représenté au sein de notre commission
des finances Monsieur Serge
d'assau merci monsieur le Président euh
monsieur le ministre vous nous imposez
20 milliards d'impôts
supplémentaires et euh vous croyez
maintenir la
croissance totalement faux car ces
impôts vont démotiver tous les chef
d'entreprise ils vont les empêcher
d'embaucher et d'investir ils n'en
auront plus les moyens donc pas de
croissance et les responsables des PME
toalement démotivés les PME que vouleit
soutenir totalement démotivé par votre
décision d'augmenter les plusvalues en
cas de cession or leur but leur action
c'est ça faire croître leur entreprise
pour les vendre sils ne peuvent pas
aller plus loin et bien il les vendront
plus ils ne croitront plus et vous
n'aurez rien vous n'aurez pas les 0,8 %
et si vous l'avez pas on fera faillite
il vous manquera 10 à 20 milliards
d'euros que vous n'aurez pas et je vrais
vous proposer comme je l'ai dit en
séance au lieu d'augmenter les impôts
qui en poisonne tout le monde aux
conséquences dramatiques il y a une
solution simple immédiate mais que vous
voulez pas faire pour des
questions bon opinion l'augmentation de
la
TVA à 23 % je parle pas TVA sociale la
TVA comme l'ont fait les Allemands
les Allemands l'ont fait et avec ces
recettes ils ont équilibré le budget ils
n'ont pas augmenté les impôts alors vous
vous vous privez d'une augmentation 23
milliards peut-être plus car vous pouvez
augmenter les TV et supprimer les
dérogations comme celle de la des
restaurants et compagnie et il y en a
d'autres et vous aurez peut-être plus
encore peut-être 30 milliards et vous
n'aurez pas a besoin d'augmenter les
impôts et vous serez euh les rois de la
finance si je puux
dire alors c'est simple vous voulez pas
le faire pour des questions disons
idéologiques parce que vous avez
critiqué la T mais on s'en fiche le
problème c'est de résoudre l'économie et
de ne pas la la la tuer avec ces impôts
qui sont stupides et qui sont inutile et
vous cherchez de l'économie il y en a
deux qui sont simples qui vous
rapporteront même 10 milliards
la prime pour l'emploi qu'on sert à rien
et que l'on reconnaî qu'il n'a aucune
influence et la restauration ça fait
presque 10 milliards donc vous es déjà
la moitié des impôts que vous pouvez
supprimer et puis je vrais quand même
vous mettre en garde parce qu'on n parle
pas
que un
danger peut-être assez immédiat qui
serait catastrophique pour la France et
pour nous tous c'est la réduction de
notre notation et l'augmentation des
tour d'intérêts ça nous pend au nez si
je puis dire parce que vous faites le
contraire de ce qu' recommandé Bruxelles
et la Cour des comptes que vous voulez
pas entendre et qui vous l'a dit
n'augmentez pas les dépenses réduisez
les dépenses d'augmenter par les impôts
et vous vous résoudrez le problème vous
faites l'inverse alors si vous faites
l'inverse c'est votre droit je pense que
ça ne marchera pas malheureusement parce
que nous allons tous son pastir disons
euh mais vous ne roudrez rien et euh si
jamais nous avons cette augmentation et
toutérêt on est fichu car on sera en ces
Sion de paiement on aura une dette une
charge de la dette qui va augmenter euh
les empruns de
100 20 160 milliards par an qu'onon va
faire et ben ils seront plus à 0 % ils
seront peut-être à 3 4 5 6 % et en fera
comment alors voilà bon conseil que je
vous propose va être un peu tard mais
quand même réfléchissez augmenter la TVA
et réduire les impôts n'augmentz pas les
impôts al merci à Monsieur Serge d'ASS
par souci de diversité je vais demander
à Monsieur Yannick
Botrel merci monsieur le
Président moi je je voudrais dire que si
on considère qu'on ne peut indéfiniment
insulter l'avenir il faut saluer
l'effort de redressement des des
finances publiques qui est qui est
contenu dans ce budget je voudrais
intervenir sur un point tout à fait
particulier qui porte sur la fiscalité
monsieur le ministre du Budget a fait
tout à l'heure état d'un mécanisme de
décôte qui pourrait concerner les
contribuables les plus modestes et il se
trouve que la loi de finances de l'année
2012 contenait une disposition qui a pu
dans l'instant
passer inaperçu à la plupart des des
contribuables ou au public en
général mais qui a produit ces effets et
et cela s'est avéré quand les feuilles
d'impôt sont arrivées dans dans les
foyers je veux parler de la
nonannexation ou du gel comme on veut du
barê de de l'imposition et ça a eu pour
effet de faire contribuer des personnes
vraiment de revenu faible alors ma
question est la suivante j'ai bien
entendu euh
faire état il y a un instant de ce
mécanisme de décôte ce qui m'importe de
savoir c'est ce que deviennent ces
contribuables qui ont quelquefois des
revenus mais alors extrêmement bas je
dirais de l'ordre de 1000 € par mois
pour une personne veuve et cetera donc
est-ce que c'est c'est contribuable et
de sont pris en considération dans ce
mécanisme de décôe dont vous avez parlé
monsieur le ministre du Budget merci à
Monsieur Botrel je passe la parole à
Monsieur Jean
Germain merci Monsieur le le président
monsieur le ministre
donc vous présentez un budget un prjet
de loi de un projet de loi de
programmation des des finances publiques
pour les années 2012 à à 2017
qui
satisfait un certain nombre d'entre nous
puisque après de de nombreuses années de
budget laxiste et de de régulation
financière faible il semble qu'il y ait
un coup de frein qui soit qui soit donné
et évidemment pour en voir les résultats
il y a un besoin de
patience une patience que que nous
pouvons avoir mais le besoin de patience
manque très souvent au
marché donc ma question portera sur sur
la croissance et sur l'intégration
européenne soutenant tout ce qui a été
dit que je trouve pour ma part très très
positif donc c'est très bien plus qu'en
période d'état extrêmement endetté des
relance de type kenésienne des grands
emprunts pour des grands projets si on
veut résumer c'est un peu derrière nous
mais par
contre est-ce
que la Banque européenne
d'investissement pourrait ne pourrait
pas intervenir plus qu'elle ne le fait
actuellement est-ce que vous excluez
complètement un plan européen de de
croissance non pas un plan des États
mais un plan européen de croissance sens
intégrant les grandes entreprises qui
ont des
liquidités pense à des grandes
entreprises automobiles ou d'aviation ou
autres qui serait lié dans un plan
européen de croissance alors je sais que
parler du plan en ce moment peut
paraître parfois certains terribles mais
comme moi je pense
que l'efficacité du marché du point de
vue théorique est égale à à à ceux qui
disaient que la terre était plate je
pense que un plan européen de croissance
englobant les grandes entreprisees qui
ont des liquidités investissant
massivement dans la croissance verte
serait je pense quelque chose à
envisager ou en tous les cas à proposer
au débat pour donner un espoir dans une
période qui est noire et où tout le
monde accepte les efforts que vous
proposez enfin le plus grand nombre mais
il y a besoin d'avoir une visibilité et
d'avoir une sortie qui arrive quelque
part c'est c'est le même sujet je le
pense sur euh le fait de s'attaquer aux
inégalités pour doper la croissance
parce que pour moi en tous les cas vous
indiquez une politique fiscale
évidemment pour une France plus juste
mais je pense aussi que la la justice
fiscale la lutte contre les inégalités
est un puissant moteur de croissance et
ceux aujourd'hui qui s'étonnent du taux
à 75 % au-delà de de de de de 1 million
d'euros de de revenus devrait réouvrir
tous les ouvrages de de de finances
publiques et de fiscalité pour voir que
aux États-Unis ça a été dit mais aussi
en Grande-Bretagne il y a pas que la
période de tcherienne en Grande-Bretagne
on a été à des taux de 98 % et
que cette cet effort de lutte contre les
inégalité fait qu'il y a plus de
dépenses sans plus d'emprunt il faut une
condition c'est qu'il y ait quand même
une sorte de coopération à l'intérieur
de l'Europe pour que les politiques ne
soient pas euh si différentes les unes
des autres et donc ma question c'est
comment voyez-vous le le chemin vers
cela deuxième question très rapide
concernant les les collectivités
territoriales comme mon collègue
François patria j'ai pour l'instant mais
j'en suis satisfait le plaisir de
pouvoir cumuler la faction à la fois ma
fonction de de sénateur et celle de de
maire d'une grande ville et et dans ce
cadre là qui je pense permet d'avoir un
un un regard mais je veux dire qui n'est
pas hors sol sur les sur les
sujets je pense que comment dire la la
diminution de de l'aide de l'État
collectivité territoriale peut se
concevoir mais que dans le cadre
évidemment de l'acte 3 de la
décentralisation ça suppose de la
clarification et une autonomie fiscale
au collectivité territoriale qui soit
pas contraire à à à vos objectifs
financiers et de et de désendettement de
l' état mais qui permettent aussi de
continuer à investir localement sur les
sujets qui permettent de de créer de
l'emploi et je m'arrêterai là je pense
notamment au logement où finalement on
sait que quand on a une politique qui
rapproche le logement et l'emploi on a
une création de d'emploi et une baisse
du chômage
immédiate vous voyez monsieur le
ministres cumule des mandats assure une
meilleure circulation de l'information
et et permett une meilleure pédagogie et
dans un sens et dans l'autre et et je
pense que les propos de jean-germain
vont au cœur et surtout rencte les
convictions large majorité d'entre nous
et la parole est à Jean-Paul et morine
merci merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues moi je vous poserai qu'une
question parce que j'ai entendu beaucoup
de choses mais j'avais presque
l'impression à un moment donné en
attentendant les discours que je
devenais amnésique mais bon la la
démocratie fait qu'on peut peut entendre
d'autres discours simplement un point
c'est sur l'article 55 de ce projet de
loi de finance sur l'élargissement du
crédit d'impôt recherche à certaines
dépenses d'innovation pour les PME notre
collègue Michel Berson a présenté un
rapport au Sénat sur le crédit impô
recherche je crois la l'analyse globale
était que la le crédit impôt recherche
était une très bonne chose pour nos
entreprises l'élargissement au PME j'y
souscrit tout à fait mais nous avions eu
un débat avec mon collègue patria sur
les grands groupe parce que je voudrais
connaître votre position sur les grands
groupes parce que par le passé le crédit
impôt recherche pour nos grands groupes
qui vont à l'exportation et je pense
surtout à un groupe qui est d'actualité
EADS où il y a Airbus eurocopterère
Astrium et qui sont en compétition à
l'international et le Crédit Impôt
Recherche leur donnait des facilités
quand même dans l'innovation par rapport
au grands groupes américain qui souvent
ont une recherche qui est financée par
le ministère de la Défense je voulais
tout simplement pour poser la question
est-ce que vous avez conservé ce crédit
impôtrecherge pour nos grands groupes
qui font quand même part des de du
dynamisme de notre pays merci au
président et Maine la parole est à Ivan
Collin oui monsieur le Président merci
messieurs les les ministres de façon
très brève messieur les ministres vous
avez décidé d'augmenter le nombre de
fonctionnaires dans trois ministères dit
prioritaires et ce tout en conservant un
effectif global constant pourriez-vous
nous dire tout simplement quels sont les
les ministères qui verront leurs
effectifs baisser voilà la question est
simple et concise
merci plis mais tu attendras la réponse
je peux ah non non non ah non si tu
poses la question faut attendre la
réponse alors
bon alors donc merci au président ivon
Collin
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Vincent
Placé qui s'est engagé
à qui s'est engagé à attendre la
réponse moi je je ti monsieur le
Président monsieurs les ministres mes
chers amis mes chers collègues comme
certains peut-être le savent je tiens
mes engagements donc je présente déjà
mes excuses pour ne pas pouvoir écouter
la réponse car nous avons et je le dis
pour les non non non mais je le dis pour
mes collègues de de l'opposition
sénatorial nous avons tous les mardis un
rendez-vous politique amical est
président de groupe de la majorité à
19h15 donc vous voyez je suis déjà 20
minutes en retard je le reconnais je le
reconnais
voilàz allez vas-y vasy donc je vous
présente mes excuses mais plus vous
manifestez plus ça dur évidemment donc
rapidement parce qu'effectivement comme
l'a dit notre collègue beaufil on va pas
faire le débat TSG lo organique lo de
programmation loi de
finance dans ses attendus généraux donc
donc je comme justement je veux faire
court je fais court mais je vois quand
même que même si il y a des analyses de
départ ou des axiomes de départ
différents entre madame beofice Serge
d'assau et Vincent DEAE il y a une
conclusion bizarrement assez commune
c'est-à-dire que l'année prochaine il
n'y aura probablement pas la croissance
attendue donc quand dans
aussi large travé de notre haute
assemblée souvent perspicace il y a
cette interrogation y compris avec des
analy de départ différentes j'attire
l'attention du Gouvernement sur ce sujet
car je fais partie également de celles
et ceux qui sont extrêmement inquier par
rapport à la situation mondiale
européenne bien sûr mais également la
situation française et quelque part et
oui monsieur le ministre du Budget vous
pouvez souffler mais quelque part je
tiens aussi à manifester mon
interrogation et pour le coup comme on a
pu le dire une réunion de avec mon
groupe nous pourrons y compris nous
donner rendez-vous au prochain collectif
pour rectifier tout cela mais ce n'est
pas tout à fait le sens des questions
que je voulais
poser deux petites d'ailleurs très très
techniques mais qui ont un sens y
compris par rapport aux engagements du
Président de la République pourquoi ce
seuil de l'ISF maintenu et pas abaissé
et également pourquoi ne pas plafonner
le crédit impo recherche alors on peut
faire des analyses sur les deux sujets
mais je crois savoir que dans la
campagne électorale du président de la
République on s'était plutôt engagé à
plafonner le crédit imporrecherche pour
plutôt aider les PME PMI innovantes et
pas créer des effets de Ben des grands
groupes mais c'éta les argumentations
d'avant le mois de mai sur la fiscalité
écologique alors sans trop faire de
boutade je sais pas qui fait la
communication
du du gouvernement sur les beaux
documents que nous recevons bon soit le
le communiant est pas du tout écolo soit
il est pas
malin parce que on a un beau document
donc sur remettre la justice au cœur du
système fiscal donc on a sur la
progressivité l'imposition des personnes
et je salue ce volet des recettes je
trouve qu'il y a un volontarisme et un
équilibre l'imposition des entreprises
en faveur des PME c'est tout à fait
intéressant aussi et je salue encore
encore plus sur la fiscalité mobilisée
en faveur du logement et je trouve que à
cet égard on me dit queion été franche
et sincère avec la ministre de l'Égalité
territoir du logement mais cela Abou à
quelque choseefficace et
là politiquement on un 4è point amorcer
la transition vers une fiscalité
écologique alors pourquoi c'est pas très
communiquant parce que c'est il y a une
feuille sur la
TGAP 38 millions
d'euros c'est vraiment c'est vraiment la
l'amorce c'est le c'est vraiment le
début de l'amorceur donc je pense que
pour les prochains documents il vaut
mieux pas le mettre parce que c'est
quand même assez irritant y compris je
pense que ça pourrait mécontenter le
président de la République qui lui a
fait des annonces très fortes tout à la
fois devant en France Nature
Environnement par rapport à la nécessité
de comme l'a dit d'ailleurs très bien
notre collègue Fabien Keller la
nécessité de changer de politique
fiscale en matière de fiscalité
écologique pour y compris changer les
comportements et favoriser la protection
de l'environnement mais aussi créer des
emplois donc cette question de fiscalité
écologique est extrêmement important
dans le Grenel de de Nicolas Sarkozi
jean-l Blau il y avait eu l'entame du
débat sur la taxe carbone la
contribution énergie climat moi je
souhaite avoir des réponses du
Gouvernement sur ce sujet je souhaite
avoir des réponses sur les thèmes que
nous avons portés sur les niches
fiscales antiécolo celle qui favorise
extrêmement le le kérosen y compris dans
son trafic aérien intérieur la question
de du diesel qui est extrêmement
préoccupante en matière de santé
environnement et qui quelque part nous
met dans une NACE industrielle
commerciale car étant les seuls à peu
près dans le monde à être autant
impliqué dans le diesel on voit bien la
difficulté exportation d'un un grand
groupe qui a subi différents éléments de
communication pendant cet été les
pesticides les agrocarburants voyez que
on nous avons des thèmes extrêmement
forts que nous souhaitons porter je
donne d'ailleurs pe me permet pour le
coup d'après de porter un petit conseil
parce que comme il me semble également
qu'on ne cherche pas à trouver des
marges politiques industrielles
volontaristes de la puissance publique
pourquoi n'essayons pas nous pas sur les
22 milliards de niches fiscal antiolo
d'en trouver un/3 un/4 même un 5e pour
abonder la banque d'investissement pour
justement entamer cette conversion
écologique que beaucoup de pays divers
et variés comme les États-Unis la Chine
le Danemark la Corée du Sud se lance et
là nous sommes en train de rater si je
dire le train de la transition
écologique qui est pour le coup porteuse
de développement et d'emploi y compris
sur les transports collectifs il n'y a
pas grandchose dans le budget et là
aussi c'est toute à la fois d'ailleurs
le Francilien et l'écologiste qui parle
parce que sur le Grand Paris mon
collègue de lae s'est interrogé il
semblait que des arbitrages plutôt plus
positifs que que ce qu'il y a dans la
loi de finan actuelle était établi pour
justement faire en sorte qu'on améliore
madame bofice a parlé du RB il y a
effectivement beaucoup de travail sur le
futur Grand Paris Express et sur a RB
une cause qui d'ailleurs rassemble les
élus franciliens de tout bord et je
crois que là il y a des questions qui se
posent sur tous les bancs mais vous avez
pu voir aussi depuis ce matin dans la
presse voilà donc toutes mes excuses
d'avoir été trop longs et puis encore
plus mes excuses de ne pas écouter la
réponse même si je la lirai avec
l'attention que les éminents ministres
qui sont présents méritent et que je
soutiens dans leur action globale je
vous
remercie merci à Monsieur le Président
placé pour cette intervention très
substantielle et je passe la parole à
Monsieur Claude bot
oui monsieur le Président mieur
messieurs les
ministres moi je je souhaite la réussite
de mon
pays et et je souhaite que
on été souscrit dans une période où il y
avait le feu il y a pas si longtemps
soit puiss être épongé et que notre que
notre pays retrouve sa sa force et son
sérieux 3 % oui il faut le faire cette
année arriver à zéro dans le plus bref
délai il faut y
parvenir il faut y parvenir
mais par les moyens qui sont qui sont
peut-être plus appropriés que ceux que
vous proposez parce que nous sommes
toujours dans une économie libérale dans
laquelle les agents de création de
richesse agissent librement et donc il
faut avoir leur confiance tout le
système repose sur un sur un un postulat
simple
méfiance confiance aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui
méfiez-vous de ne pas pas créer chez
tous ceux qui ont capacité à faire
réussir notre pays une méfiance telle
qu'il n'agiront point ou qu'ils agiront
ailleurs alors à partir de là à partir
de là on peut regarder où faut-il où
faut-il réussir
à à trouver des des marges des marges
d'économie dans l'état sans
doute mais ça c'est votre c'est votre
travail
dans les collectivités locales
j'administre depuis longtemps des
j'exercais j'exerce toujours des
responsabilités significative et j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure ce que disait
François patria et ce que ce que disait
jean-gmain sur les collectivités local
il ne s'agit pas d'une d'une vache
sacrée de la République il y a de bons
ouvrages qui sortent en ce
moment on observe ici ou là des
anomalies hier j'étais dans une réunion
sur réaliste où la préfette se battait à
tout prix pour essayer de créer une une
communauté
d'agglomération et la communauté
d'agglomération l'argument majeur c'est
que elle va elle va toucher des sommes
euh vertigineuse de la part de l'État
hein alors voilà le voilà la quand même
les voilà quand même les les choses
telles qu'elles sont faudra bien en
sortir
des euh des des des des des des des
compétences entre les uns et les autres
a aujourd'hui tout le monde fait la même
chose il faudra bien en sortir nous
allons avoir dans cette maison prèemain
et le 4 et le 5 une une réunion dont
j'espère qu'elle sera réussie je tiens à
le dire ici et et et que on ça ne soit
pas une démagogie en plus une séance de
démagogie en plus pour que les
collectivités puissent
défendre penser allègrement je l'espère
vivement et je le dis à la majorité
nationale et
sénatoriale soyons sérieux soyons
sérieux il y a des marges de manœuvre
importantes à ce niveau-là j'en suis
j'en suis profondément profondément
convaincu alors ça c'est ce que c'est ce
que je voulais dire ne mettez pas s'il
vous plaît ce pays en état
d'hibernation il y a un risque sérieux
en ce moment vous ne trouverez pas les
la croissance si vraiment vous ne faites
pas confiance aux agents économiques
naturels ceux qui peuvent créer des
richesses et ceux qui dépense l'argent
public qu'il s'agisse de l'État des
collectivités faites en sorte que ma
fois les choses changent et vous avez
une possibilité de jouer sur le
changement il y a le changement il y a
le pouvoir normatif on vit depuis
plusieurs années depuis 10 ans 15 ans 20
ans encore à l'ire de la
décentralisation mieur les élus on vous
file des responsabilités et on décide
les la façon dont vous allez dépenser
l'argent public y compris celui qu'on
vous donne j'avais sorti un petit
bouquin ici il y a quelques années il y
a quelques années il y a moins de 2 ans
400000 normes dont 380 sont discutables
he je crois qu'il faut quand même
380 400000 380000 sont discutable donc
il faut que l'État et les collectivités
est un partenariat de réussite vers la
abissement de la dépense voilà le voilà
les les choses alors je vrais intervenir
également en tant que que que rapporteur
des crédits de
l'audiovisuel vous avez proposé
d'augmenter la d'augmenter la redevance
et vous avez bien fait ça aussi c'était
une bache saacrée à laquelle il ne
fallait pas toucher la redevance bon on
a commencé à y toucher et vous continuez
vous avez raison mais où où où j'attire
votre attention sur le sur la la suite
des choses bon France Télévision est une
entreprise lourde à manier hein madame
philippetti aura bien du mal et et
Monsieur plimin aussi avec cette maison
ceci dit les recettes publicitaires sont
une ressource essentielle et s'il n'y a
pas la recette publicitaire vous serez
bien obligé d'assurer l'équilibre
budgétaire il y a un il y a un un
contrat d'objectif et de moyen qui a qui
a le mérite d'exister qui a
l'inconvénient peut-être d'exister pour
pour vous ceci dit c'est du crédit
budgétaire qu'il faudra pour équilibrer
les comptes si les recettes budgétaires
ne sont pas là parce que parce que la la
publicité se dérobe hein pour le public
et pour le privé et là vous n'avez pas
crédit prévu un centime donc moi
j'attire votre attention sur cette
situation je le dirai à la ministre
quand nous aurons l'occasion de de
parler du sujet mais vraiment vraiment
vraiment là euh vous avez vous avez dans
les dans les les mains quelque chose qui
peut très vite devenir coûteux et et
explosif à tout point de vue alors voilà
ce que je voulais vous dire je reviens
30 secondes sur la
croissance on lit dans la presse
américaine en ce moment que le le DD
Jones est revenu à un niveau supérieur à
ce qu'il était en 2007 on peut s'en
réjouir ou pas s'en réjouir mais pass
c'est quand même un bon
indicateur le DAX allemand en un mois
seulement a connu une évolution
supérieure de 7 % à ce pauvre CAC 40
tout cela veut dire quelque chose c'est
que le monde nous observe et le monde
agit ou n'agit pas en France et avec nos
entreprise hein alors voilà moi je me
permets d'assurer la de de de vous dire
tout cela
euh je le fais avec celui qui a quand
même une longe expérience de l'économie
publique et privée
et faites en sorte que notre pays
réussite s'il vous plaît et je ne suis
pas convaincu que ce que vous proposez
le
permettre merci beaucoup à Claude B et
dernier orateur inscrit Marie-Hélène
desg merci Monsieur le
prent merci monsieur le Président mieur
le ministre moi je voudrais revenir sur
sur l'effort de 30 milliards qui ser
réparti en 20 milliards d'impô
supplémentaires et 10 milliards
d'économie le premier président de la
Cour des comptes a ici même à votre
place clairement indiqué qu'il fallait
en matière de de réduction de déficit
maintenant adopter la règle de 50 %
d'impôt supplémentaires 50 % d'économie
cette règle n'est donc pas respectée
puisque là vous adoptez 2/ ti3 d'impôt
supplémentaires et 1/3 d'économie moi je
le regrette et dans le débat vous avez
tenté une explication de dire que les
économies donc seraient plus récessives
que que le l'augmentation des des des
impôts que les impôts supplémentaires
moi franchement votre explication ne me
convainc pas du tout parce que faire des
économies pour moi quelque part c'est du
structurel faire de l'augmentation de la
fiscalité c'est plutôt conjoncturel et
c'est bien des mesures structurelles
dont nous avons besoin donc je
souhaiterais que vous rejustifiez cette
position qui est je le redis une
position de renoncement à appliquer la
règle fixée par la Cour des comptes et
c'est dans sur ce point-là que je
souhaite que vous vous exprimiez enfin
je m'inquiète du respect de la règle des
des 3 % de déficit madame beffil tout à
l'heure mais bon beaucoup de grands élus
Claude barartelo narline desésir
beaucoup de grands élus de la majorité
expriment publiquement leur doute sur
l'objectif des 3 % du PIB fixé pour
2013 alors moi je voudrais que vous
confirmiez ici très clairement votre
volonté de réduire les déficits ou alors
dites-nous s'il y a des BAT est-ce qu'il
y a Desbat est-ce qu'il y a pas des BAT
est-ce qu'il s'agit de affffichage d'un
gain de temps vis-à-vis des instances
européennes moi je souhaite que
véritablement il y ait devant notre
commission des finances à cet instant un
engagement très précis parce qu'on va
revenir tous les rapporteurs spéciaux
sur nos différents budgets et cetera sur
nos différents rapports là là c'est des
grands équilibres qui s'agit et ça cette
question elle est à mes yeux extrêmement
importante et je vous remercie par
avance de la répon que voudrait bien me
faire
ah et bien chers collègues nous sommes
arrivés au terme de cette liste de 17
intervenants ce qui montre le grand
intérêt suscité par votre audition
messieurs les ministres et donc la très
grande attente à l'égard de vos
réponses nous allons faire commeons
partager les réponses je vais revenir
sur sur le MES que j'avais oublié tout à
l'heure pardon à à François Marc pour
dire qu'en effet la France est
actionnaire à un peu moins de 20 % que
la décision de la cour de carless rouvre
la la voie à sa mise en place et
s'agissant de de de des conséquences
financières que la dotation en capital
est à la hauteur de notre part soit 6,5
milliards en 2012 et 16,3 milliards sur
la période
2012-2014 avec une toute petite
restriction qui est que l'Estonie n'a
pas encore ratifié mais elle représente
0,18 % elle va le faire et puis le MS
n'est pas comptabilisé en tête publique
car il est suffisamment capitalisé il
fonctionne comme une banque donc sur le
plan technique tout est prêt et
effectivement le 8 octobre en marge du
Conseil Ecofin à Luxembourg le MES sera
installé euh et il pourra continuer sur
le paquet croissance et c'est une
question de Richard Jung notamment euh
je veux dire que en effet c'est un
paquet qui est significatif 120
milliards d'euros euh c'est en gros une
année de budget
la BEI a fait voter son augmentation de
capital avec du coup une augmentation
qui de la capacité de prêt qui sera de
60 milliards sur 3 ans avec là encore
une petite restriction je voyais ce
matin le vice-président de la Bui c'est
que la Bulgarie n'a pas encore voter
qu'il faut un vote unanime des
gouverneurs enfin j'espère que cela sera
le cas et moi qui suis le gouverneur de
la France à la BI au conseil de
gouverneur je je ferai en sorte pousser
dans cette direction les les project
bonds euh je travaillais ce matin
justement sur l'identification en France
je pense notamment à deux secteurs à
court terme le numérique le passage au
débit dans un certain nombre de régions
et départements et des infrastructures
de transport a dit un certain nombre
d'autoroute ou de Tron au monsieur le
ministre nous commençons par là monsieur
le Président euh mais il y a là quelque
chose qui est significatif et l'idée
c'est bien de faire en sorte que
l'orientation des crédits de la banque
européenne investissement aille
davantage sur la France pourrait passer
de 4 milliards aujourd'hui à 7 milliards
dans peu d'années et pourquoi pas dès
l'année prochaine c'est ce à quoi je
travaille et avec la BEI nous allons
mobiliser nos efforts ensemble je
souhaite aussi que la BEI soit associer
à la PPI comme elle a pu le faire auprès
de la KfW allemande ça c'est un premier
point et
deuxièmement que la PEI puisse
contribuer au financement des hôpitaux
car il y a un besoin de financement
d'investissement hospitaliers qui ne
peuvent pas trouver leur place dans un
cadre principalement budgétaire on le
sait mais à la fois les enveloppes de la
Caisse des Dépôts et Consignation sur
l'envelop 3 milliards il est prévu 500
millions d'euros qui vont dans ce
sens-là et la Bui nous pouvons là
trouver des financements qui sont des
financements intelligents pour nos
structures hospitalières sur la
transaction la taxe sur les transactions
financières vous savez ce qu'il en est
c'estàdire que le conseil européens des
28 et 29 juin a constaté nous l'avons
fait à regret qu'il n'y avait pas
d'accord pour une taxe sur les
transactions financières ni à l'échelle
de l'Union européenne et 27 ni à
l'échelle des 17 donc ce qui a été
décidé c'est que il y aurait une
coopération renforcée qui suppose la la
Réunion d'au moins u États-membres qui
sur la base des travaux de la commission
pourrait intervenir d'ici à la fin de
l'année 2012 euh mais pour que la
Commission puisse être actionnée il faut
qu'il y ait auparavant les 9uf
États-membres qui se
signalent nous avons si j'étais un
commerçant je dirais des touches une
douzaine d'état-membres qui sont
disponibles certains sont hésitants je
pense à l'Espagne et à l'Italie et c'est
la raison pour laquelle avec volgang
Chaou nous avons pris l'initiative de
nous adresser à ceux qui étaient
potentiellement disponibles pour dire
nous nous sommes prêts nous avons des
visions qui sont extrêmement comparables
et ce que j'attends j'ai pas de de
réponse immédiate mais j'aurai beaucoup
de contacts en marche justement de ces
réunions de l'Eurogroupe et de l' F
lundi et mardi ce que j'attends c'est B
et bien que nous trouvions ces neuf
étatsmembres au moins en réalité il y en
aura plus très vite pour pouvoir avancer
sur la base de propositions qui nous
seront faites par la Commission à partir
de ce qu'elle avait elle-même suggéré au
Conseil Ecofin et au Conseil européen
auparavant jeard Michel a évoqué la
question des des impôts locaux et nous
sommes d'accord pour dire que ces impôts
locaux doivent être prise en compte dans
le débat sur le pouvoir d'achat c'est
l'évidence c'est raison pour laquelle
les seuils d'exonération et de
dégrvement de la fiscalité locale seront
relevés en même temps que le montant de
la décote euh vous posez également la
question la révision des bases locative
cadastrale sur amendement qui était je
crois un amendement de François Marc au
Sénat vous avez lors du dernier
collectif adopté un calendrier pour les
valeurs locatrifes notamment sur les
locaux professionnels et je peux vous
assurer ainsi que Jérôme que la DG fiple
la direction générale des finances
publiques se prépare activement à la
mise en œuvre de cette réforme que vous
vous avez souhaité vous-même plusieurs
d'entre vous nous ont interrogé sur la
prévision de croissance à commencé par
Monsieur de laai mais aussi de la mais
aussi monsieur dassasso mais aussi
monsieur placé et quelques autres madame
des esgo dans sa dernière intervention
je
crois la prévision qui est retenue est
une prévision qui est à la fois réaliste
et volontariste elle est réaliste si
nous nous avions dit plus de 0,8 en
effet l'écart au consensus qui est
autour de 0,5 aurait été supérieur à ce
qui est communément admissible et on
aurait pu nous accuser d'insincérité et
l'insincérité aurait entraîné cette
accusation d'cérité un regard négatif
sur notre budget or nous tenons
essentiellement je le dis au passage à
tous madame befice aussi à la
crédibilité parce que en effet nous ne
voulons pas d'une France qui tombe entre
les mains des marchés je le redis c'est
un enjeu de souveraineté qui est tout à
fait fondamental et pour que cette
crédibilité soit maintenue pour que la
qualité de notre signature persiste
alors il est fondamental que notre
budget soit tout à fait carré tout à
fait crédible mais c'est aussi
volontarist puisque nous sommes
effectivement au-dessus des prévisions
qui sont celles du consensus des
économistes ce que je prétends en effet
c'est pas une originalité mais ce que je
ce que je prétends c'est que aujourd'hui
il est absolument impossible en vérité
d'évaluer la croissance pour 2013 à plus
ou moins 0,5 points tant il est vrai que
les incertitudes européennes pèsent
lourd il y a les aléas négatifs pourquoi
les négliger il y a les aléas positifs
si l'Europe met derrière elle la
question de la Grèce c'est possible dans
quelques jours si elle met derrière elle
la question espagnole c'est possible
dans le mois si elle avance sur la
supervision bancaire nous y travaillons
activement alors ce qui est en train de
se passer parce que interroger des
acteurs économiques vous-même ça pour le
coup c'est pas une question de politique
droite gauche ils vous diront que la
zone euro est en train de sortir de
l'ordnière mais la question c'est la
vitesse la question c'est la profondeur
c'est aussi ce que suggérait tout à
l'heure jean-germain dans son
intervention et bien une accélération du
processus et quelque chose qui irait
plus loin plus fort plus vite c'est de
nature en effet à créer des
anticipations je lisais il y a quelques
temps l'estimation d'une économiste
madame Lemoine qui je pense n'est pas
connu pour re tout à fait socialiste qui
est très brillante qui a participé à
plusieurs cabinets de droite c'est pas
lu faire l'jure de HSBC et elle disait
que pour ce qui la concerné elle pensait
que ce serait 09 l'an prochain
c'estàdire audessus du consensus je
pense que en effet c'est une possibilité
et ce que j'ai observé comme Jérôme
Cahusac lors du débat à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est que je parle à
l'opposition sénatoriale comme je
pourrais m'adresser comme nous sommes
adressés à l'opposition à l'Assemblée
bah vos collègues de de l'opposition
avait estimé en effet que le
gouvernement était dans son droit dans
sa logique et n'avait pas contesté cette
prévision de croissance je crois pour ma
part encore une fois qu'elle induit une
dose de volontarisme qui est acceptable
c'est ce que j'ai envie de de dire quant
à 2 % à partir de
2014 je mentionnerai simplement le fait
qu'avec une croissance effective de 2 %
notre niveau d'activité ne rejoindrait
toujours pas son potentiel en 2017 que 2
% puisqu'on est bien ici évoquer
l'histoire des crises c'est c'est
inférieur à ce qu'on observe
actuellement habituellement en sorti de
crise et enfin que nous raisonnons aussi
en croissance potentielle et vous aurez
noté que notre scénario de croissance
potentielle est prudent puisque nous
nous retenons l'hypothèse conventionnel
redressement proguctif de 2014 à 2017
l'accélération reflétant l'impact des
réformes engagées au cours du quinquena
de 1,1 % en 2011 à 1,6 % en
2017 j'ai j'ai répondu d'un Moot à
Madame bofice mais je peux aller un peu
plus
loin en lui disant que nous ne rençons
pas à l'équilibre des finances publiques
qu'en 2017 le sol nomina sera bien
autour de l'équilibre à - 03 % que le
sold structurel sera lui à l'équilibre
mais que nous le faisons de façon
intelligente sans casser la croissance
et encore une fois avec un souci qu'elle
partage si elle ne partage pas notre
appréciation sur le TSCG qui est nous
affranchir des marchés de ne pas tomber
entre leurs mains euh je reviens aux
questions de Monsieur de qui était
nombreuse et documenté pour évoquer deux
sujets d'abord l'Union européenne qu'il
a
lui-même évoqué Union européenne avec le
fait que nous sommes maintenant dans
quelques mois dans la discussion du
paquet financier sur l'Union européenne
et la France dans cette discussion nous
sommes en train d'y réfléchir à
l'échelle interministérielle nous avons
encore un peu de temps c'est
traditionnellement le ministre d'
affaires européennes qui qui porte cette
discussion mais les finances bien sûr
ont leur mots à dire un peu plus que ça
nous serons dans une position médiane
nous ne pouvons pas être parmi les pays
qui veulent des coupes sauvages sur la
dépense communautaire parce que ça
risquerait d'atteindre les politiques
existantes je pense à la politique
agricoolle commune et parce que ça
empêcherait de mener des politiques de
croissance c'est ce que nous voulons
mais nous ne voulons pas non plus être
dans des prévisions ou dans des actions
qui seraient excessivement
expansionnistes nous n'avons pas les
moyens aujourd'hui et nous essaierons
d'avoir cette position raisonnable
défendant à la fois une politique à
laquelle nous sommes attachés la
politique agricole communes des
politiques structurelles qui sont
importantes pour nos territoirees et
urbains et ruraux et préservant des
capacités de financement innovant
justement pour développer moderniser
notre économie vous avz évoqué les
réformes structurelles mot réformes
structurelles c'est un mot valise dont
il faut se méfier car il est redoutable
il y a une Vulgate pour le coup qui est
une Vulgate extrêmement libér qui n'est
pas forcément celle que nous allons
adopter qui n'est pas celle que nous
allons adopter s'agissant de réformes
mais des réformes de structure il faut
en faire pour une raison simple c'est
que clairement la compétitivité de la
France s'est dégradée au cours des 10
dernières années et les meilleurs
indicateurs c'est les pars de marché
l'export c'est le déficit commercial ça
résulte à la fois d'une compétitivité
prix mais aussi d'une compétitivité
horors prix tendance à dire plutôt d'une
compétitivité hors prix et donc on va
aborder la question sansou comment il y
a le rapport de Monsieur Galois qui sera
rendu dans le courant du mois d'octobre
il y a un conseil euh sur le financement
de la protection sociale qui a été
installé ou réinstallé par le Premier
ministre la semaine dernière qui était
complété c'était prévu en mars nous
l'avons maintenant mis en œuvre il y a
un calendrier et des mesures seront
prises qui seront des mesures
compétitives je citeraai dans l'ordre ou
dans le désordre plutôt la
simplification administrative hier se
tenait un un conseil interministérielle
une réunion de ministre sur euh la
modernisation de l'administration c'est
un facteur qui est très attendu la
stabilité fiscale et la neutralité d'une
politique plus favorable au PME et à
l'innovation pour préserver
l'investissement des réformes
sectorielles il en faudra dans les
secteurs comme le transport ou le
logement et puis tout ce qui concerne le
paquet dont je suis responsable de du
financement de l'économie banque
publique d'investissement réforme de
l'épargne réglementée réforme de
l'épargne financière avec un objectif
qui est d'allonger la durée de l'éparne
financière j'étais invité à déjeuner par
le bureau de la Fédération française des
sociétés d'assurance j'ai pu leur dire
et je le dis ici que nous n'avons pas
l'intention de toucher à la fiscalité de
l'assurance vie si ce n'est dans un sens
qui éventuellement permettrait de
l'aventter deallanger davantage encore
et donc notre souci c'est de faire en
sorte que nos entreprises trouvent les
financements longs dont elles ont besoin
et trouve aussi des financements tout
court c'est le rôle de la BPI
financement par des prê financement par
les garanties financement par les
apports en capital le BPI qui sera la
banque des PME PMI la banque des régions
et un investisseur stratégique de long
terme car elle ne doit pas être une
banque comme les autres elle doit aussi
se fixer comme objectif non pas de
rechercher une rentabilité à court terme
et excessive qui peut être prédatrice
mais une rentabilité de long terme c'est
ça que nous voulons faire et ce sont
monsieur le sénateur je veux vous
l'assurer des
euh mesures qui sont tout à fait des
réformes de structure elles ne le sont
peut-être pas au sens de tel ou telle
littérature anglo-saxonne mais ce sont
des vraies modifications de structure et
quand je vais discuter avec Monsieur
reen par exemple à la Commission
européenne je lui dis toujours la même
chose je dis nous voulons être juger sur
nos résultats ce qu'on nous demande
c'est quoi c'est une France crédible des
maîtrise des objectifs de finances
publiques nous le ferons on nous demande
des changements nous les ferons mais
nous voulons aussi être maître de nos
propres moyens et ça c'est tout à fait
fondamental la politique que nous
proposons c'est une politique sérieuse
et mais c'est une politique de gauche et
nous assumons tout à fait cela madame
Keller a dit sa fiscalité sa passion
pour la fiscalité écologique je ne vais
pas dire ce que me souffla l'oreille le
président ce serait déloyal sur la
passion fiscale mais les mesures qui
sont prises en loi finance initiale ne
sont pas cher Fabien Keller anecdotique
c'estàd que le rendement de la TGAP r
sera doublé euh des mesures étaient
d'ailleurs urgentes parce que que la
France déplace les plafonds des missions
qu'elle est tenue de respecter et vous
savez bien qu'il y ait aussi un plan
automobile avec le durcissement des
malus et enfin qu'il y a cette
conférence environnementale qui a lancé
plusieurs pistes sur l'eau sur les
déchets sur le carbone sur les véhicules
sur la biodiversité pistes qui seront
exploré conformément aux engagements
contenus dans la feuille de route de la
conférence environnementale donc je
tiens à vous rassurer comme je rassure
monsieur placé euh il n'y a pas là
d'abandon d'une ambition et j'ajoute
qu'un un un conseil permanent de suivi
de la fiscalité écologique incluant je
pense que ça vous intéresser des
parlementaires les ONG les partenaires
sociaux sera prochainement installé pour
y veiller ça prend un peu plus de temps
dans un contexte qui c'est vrai est un
contexte tout de même assez compliqué en
matière budgétaire mais ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui est en quoi que ce
soit abandonné ou sur lequel il y a un
recul monsieur dasso bon il a exprimé
son opinion moi je pense que ça va
marcher je pense en effet c'est aussi
une réponse à Mame des ESG que les choix
que nous avons fait sont des choix qui
sont économiquement pertinents
c'estàdire que sur la durée du quinen ce
sera bien 50 50 dépense recette mais à
court terme c'est vrai nous ne voulons
pas mettre en place une politique
d'austérité affaiblir l'État à l'excès
même s'il y a des vraies dépenses et
nous mettons en place des des recettes
supplémentaires qui je le répète
préserve la capacité à consommer des
ménages des couches populaires des
couches moyennne et préserve aussi la
capacité à investir des grandes
entreprises qui ont tout de même
quelques moyens et des PME PMI qui sont
protégé et elles sont plus que protégé
puisqueen matière de crédit d'impôt
recherche non seulement nous
sanctuirisons ce qui existait mais nous
étendons le crédit d'impôt recherche aux
dépenses inovation des PME il sera plus
facile pour elle de le solliciter de la
part de l'administration et c'était ça
qui était le vrai engagement de François
Hollande pendant la campagne c'était de
rendre le crédit d'impôtrecherche plus
accessible au PME nous le faisons Jean
Germain moi j'ai fait dans une interview
il y a peu de temps une référence à à
Kees ce que j'ai voulu indiquer par là
c'est l' refus d'une politique
d'austérité généralisée un peu ce que
vous suggériez en Europe et notre
volonté d'infléchir justement les
politiques en Europe et le paquet
croissance j'y reviens parce que il est
d'ampleur je lu répondu à Richard jou
mais c'est une première étape on ne peut
pas s'arrêter là il faut aller plus loin
même beaucoup plus loin je note que non
seulement la BI doit financer plus mais
qu'elle va financer plus y compris en
France je redonne les chiffres 4
milliards d'euros aujourd'hui demain 7
milliards par an mais il faut pour ça
que nous identifions des projets et
c'est le sens de la coopération que j'ai
mise en œuvre avec Monsieur j'ai bien
noté le canal Sor et et et ce que j'ai
voulu dire c'est que notre stratégie
visait précisément à préserver la
demande à court terme par nos mesures en
faveur du pouvoir d'achat c'est une
analyse qui fait que nous équilibrons
pour notre part l'offre et la demande
nous pensons que c'est sur les deux
aspects qu'il faut agir en effet je
pense aussi comme jean-germain que la
lutte contre les inégalités est
favorable à la croissance opposer
l'économique et le social n'a pas de
sens c'est même une faute et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous assumons
tranquillement d'avoir et bien aussi le
dialogue social comme méthode la
recherche de consensus comme finalité
euh enfin dernier mot je vais céder la
parole à jérô kusac à Madame des exgo je
lui répondu sur le partage recette
dépens je veux simplement ajouter une
chose c'est que vous avez dit que nous
ne respections pas les règles que fixait
la Cour des comptes moi je suis ici dans
l'enceinte parlementaire euh je je je sa
quel est le rôle du gouvernement qui
propose euh un projet de loi je sais ce
qu'est le rôle du Parlement qui l'amende
qui le vote je sais ce qu'est le rôle de
la Cour des comptes je le sais d'autant
plus que je suis dans le civil
conseiller maîre à la Cour des comptes
donc j'ai le respect c'est vrai c
conflit cette lutte des class c'est
terrible entre Philippe Marini et moi
mais enfin c'est ainsi et et donc j'ai
j'ai le plus grand respect pour cette
institution mais elle évalue euh elle
suggère elle propose mais mais mais
c'est le pouvoir que nous incarnons dans
ces différentes facettes dans ces
différentes branches exécutif et
législativ qui décide et ça c'est
quelque chose à lequel je tiens et je le
dis non il y a pas de règles fixé il y a
des recommandations nous les avons
suivis très largement par exemple sur
l'ampleur de l'effort la Cour des
comptes Ava dit 33 on est revenu sur
tout à l'heure sur les 37 nous le
faisons nous n'avons pas voulu biaiser
avec ça mais il y a des choses que nous
avons retenu d'autre part la Cour des
comptes a joué un rôle extrêmement utile
de conseil euh d'évaluation de
préconisation mais nous prenons nos
responsabilités en tant que gouvernement
de la France légitime parce que j'
entendais tout à l'heure parler d'un
gouvernement technique
non la France n'est pas dans cette
situation d'avoir un gouvernement
technique heureusement ne le sera pas
cher Philippe Marini cher président et
c'est bien un gouvernement politique qui
est misise en place et je je pourrait
presque m'étonner que dans une assemblée
comme celle-ci on en appelle à un
gouvernement
technique on a appelé on a fait une
référence à la situation italienne et
d'ailleurs ce gouvernement italien est
brillant nous vous avons prêté une
attention forte et j'ai bien entendu
certains déplorer qu'il n'y ait pas de
gouvernement technique en France il y a
un gouvernement qui est sérieux
franchement j'ai pas entendu ça je vous
assure entendu mais on verra enfin
dernier mot en réponse
mais je suis d'autant plus prêt à le
retirer que nous sommes d'accord
apparemment
donc poussait un peu dans les
retranchements ce que j'ai entendu mais
je mtiens quand même ce que j'ai dis
mais dernier mot sur Madame desesg sur
les 3 % et ben dans la politique le
débat est libre chez les économistes
aussi et j'entend beaucoup d'économistes
dter des 3 % des économistes de gauche
comme les économistes de droite et tous
font d'ailleurs une réflexion qui est
assez juste c'est que les orientations
qui ont été prises à l'échelle
européenne avec le respect de ces règles
ne sont pas des mesures qui sont
expansionnistes c'est pas une
philosophie expansionniste mais je peux
vous rassurer sur une
chose ce que nous disons Jérôme kusac et
moi et c'est notre responsabilité dans
le gouvernement et nous en sommes
responsables et garant c'est ce que nous
ferons autrement dit l'objectif de 3 %
est un objectif qui ne se discute pas la
France ne le remettra pas en cause de
manière unilatérale peut-être peut-il y
avoir à tel ou tel moment des débats
européens il serait respectable j'en
entends ici sur tous les bancs qui
peuvent en appeler à cela j'ai entendu
aussi Jean Vincent placer le faire mais
nous nous avons cette obligation ce mot
a été prononcé
d'exemplarité de crédibilité de qualité
et le débat budgétaire permettra
d'illustrer à quel point c'est bien pour
nous de 3 % dont il s'agit pas 3,1 pas
3,2 pas 3 % en tendance pas 3 % à peu
près pas 3 % si on peut peu mais 3 %
bien monsieur le ministre nous sommes
beaucoup à saluer votre détermination
sur ce point alors Monsieur le Ministre
Cusac il y a encore plusieurs collègues
qui attendent des réponses que vous
allez leur rapporter on va essayer de le
rapporter notamment ine
montescue qui qui souhait davantage
d'économie d'impôts c'est c'est un
discours naturellement qu'on peut
comprendre diminuer davantage la dépense
de l'État supposerait de couper dans
dépenses d'intervention comme Laah ou
d'autres aucun gouvernement ne s'est
jamais risqué pour l'instant peut-être
un peu d'indulgence à notre égard pour
l'instant dans notre histoire politique
oui on a le droit de de viser loin
madame Keller quant à la dépense
publique elle est de 56 % du PIB en 2011
563 en 2012 on a notre part mais
d'autres aussi ça sera le même
pourcentage rapporté au PIB en 2013 et
ça commence à baisser ensuite car la
dépense va baisser par l'application de
la norme zéro valeur aux dépenses de
l'État parl dame de 7 l'année prochaine
de 6 la suivante de 5 celle d'après par
l'action très forte sur les opérateurs
dont j'ai déjà parlé et les taxes
affectées à ces opérateurs baissent déjà
dans ce projet de loit de finance d'un
peu moins de 130 millions d'euros alors
les effectifs baisseront dès 2013 il y a
12298 suppressions de postes en PF 2013
7234 dans la défense 2353 à Bery 134 à
l'intérieur 184 aux Affaires étrangères
bref tous les ministères sont touchés si
certaines missions sont préservées
l'éducation l'enseignement supérieur la
recherche la justice et bien évidemment
les forces de sécurité elle-même police
et gendarmerie dans les effectifs vont
augmenter donc je crois que la dépense
va effectivement baisser et je redis que
10 milliards d'euros d'économie nette y
compris les mesures nouvelles qui sont
déclinés dans ce projet de budget et en
liaison avec les promesses du candidat
François Hollande confirmé par le
Président de la République François
Hollande il me semble que c'est assez
significatif pour être souligné sur la
décode qui avait été soulevé par le
sénateur Berel je crois simplement pour
indiquer que sans ce mécanisme 400000
foyers rentrent à l'impôt sur le revenu
ils n'y rentreront pas sans ce mécanisme
près de 3 millions de de foyers qui sont
à la première tranche ne verront pas
leur impôt augmentés et près de 4
millions de foyers verront certes leur
impôt augmenter mais nettement moins que
ce qu'aurait été cette augmentation sans
cette décolte c'est-à-dire si la simple
application du gel de barê voté sur la
majorité précédente c'était opéré tel
qu'envisagé par les promoteurs à
l'époque de cette mesure donc je pense
que c'est un mécanisme assez puissant
qui va permettre d'éviter ce qui avait
été craint dans l'intervention de votre
collègue yannique Brel un salarié
célibataire à 1000 € par mois celui-là
est pleinement visé par le mécanisme de
la décotte et ne sera donc pas concerné
par le gel du barem cette année
précisément grâce à ce mécanisme là sur
les opérateurs et notamment le CNC don
j'ai V comprendre qu'il intéressait
beaucoup d'entre vous et notamment votre
co rapporteur à la culture c'est vrai
qu'il est sorti de la liste des
opérateurs ayant des taxes plafonnées le
gouvernement propose le Parlement
dispose convenons en effet mais vous
verrez probablement ça lors de votre
audition que au moins la politique
immobilière de cet opérateur mérite
peut-être quelques explications j'ai cru
comprendre que les immeubles avaient été
achetés pour certains d'entre eux par le
CNC en son nom propre et non pas au nom
de l'État ce qui effectivement peut
paraître un tout petit peu curieux mais
vous expertises ess ça j'en suis sûr de
manière parfaite lors de l'audition
euh établissement public de l'État sur
le créd imp pour recherche P Moscovici a
je crois répondu comme il convenait pour
Vincent placer le il n'a jamais été
prévu de plafonner le le CIR j'ai mal
compris sa question sur le seuil de
l'ISF il est maintenu je crois dans des
conditions qui sont assez compréhensible
sur l'impôt sur les sociétés euh il
augmente effectivement de 12 milliards
d'euros euh 2,3 milliards d'euros sont
des mesures techniques de périmètre et
la mise en œuvre de Corus et des
changements de nomenclature c'est donc
un effet d'affichage qui ne correspond
pas à une réalité pour 2 milliards
d'euros c'est la haut spontanée il y a
une forme d'élasticité l'impôt sur les
sociétés à la croissance chacun c'est
bien donc en fait les mesures nouvelles
ce n'est pas 12 mais 8 milliards d'euros
c'est déjà beaucoup il me paraît pas
indispensable de forcer sur cette
addition pour le Grand Paris le projet
n'est pas remis en cause madame Duflot
lors du conseil de surveillance de la
SGP en juillet a indiqué vouloir
prioriser hier hérarchiser les
composants du projet et actualiser les
coûts qui pour certains sont
probablement sous-estimés donc ça c'est
le travail qui a été confié vous le
savez le besoin de financement
n'interviendra lui qu'en 2015 ou 2016 et
si nécessaire ce sera une dotation
capital qui naturellement différent des
crédits budgétaires la dotation se fera
sur le compte d'affectation spéciale des
PFE les
participations financière de l'État
monsieur le Président la Commission des
finances en effet euh qu'je oublié que
Pierre Moscovici aurait également omis
comme réponse je ne crois pas sur la
dimission des effectifs c'estateur Colin
qui l'avait de manger je luis donné le
détail monsieur Alber de montgolfie a
indiqué son étonnement pour la
défiscalisation outremire il ne s'agit
pas de renoncer à faire quoi que ce soit
là-dessus je ne Ren rigoureusement rien
de ce qui a pu être écrit et signé vous
en doutez bien mais l'économie
ultramarine est quand même assez fragile
cette année il nous a semblé que revenir
dans ce PLF sans qu'il a de concertation
ou de simulation suffisamment
fine revenir donc sur le mécanisme de
défiscalisation risquer de créer quelque
chose qui serait pire que la
défiscalisation en revanche le travail
va être engagé pour en aller à une
meilleure efficience de la dépense
fiscale ou budgétaire outremère
l'exercice est nécessaire et je vous
assure que je développerai toute
l'énergie requise pour qu'il puisse
aboutir rendez-vous si j'ose dire dans
dans quel moi mais les chos ser dans le
collectif de
2013er un peu les
comptes collectif de fin année peut-être
pas mais en tout cas l'année prochaine
je pense que nous traiterons cette
affaire là oui sur la crnsl oui il y a
une augmentation de 135 vous le savez
vous en connaissez les raisons les
réserves sont quasiment épuisé pour
pouvoir assurer le paiement des pensions
pour cela il faut une augmentation de 1
35 % je crois que quel qu' été le
gouvernement sorti des urnes lors des
élections récentes cette décision aurait
été prise je suis prêt en prendre le
Paris aisé voilà monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs il me
semble qu'on a tenté avec Pierre
Moscovici de répondre à toutes les
questions que vous aviez pu poser de
toute manière le débat se poursuivra
bien sûr au sein de votre Enceinte de la
Commission et naturellement en séance
lorsque nous viendrons avec Pierre
Moscovici défendre ce projet de budget
d'ici là à chacun bon travail et bonne
soirée merci beaucoup mieurs les
ministres merci de votre
disponibilité voilà pour les travaux de
la commission des finances je vous
rappelle que le budget 2013 sera débattu
en séance publique à partir du Lundi 29
octobre et que vous pourrez suivre en
direct sur l'antenne de Public Sénat
tous ces débats si vous souhaitez revoir
l'audition de Jérôme Cahusac et de
Pierre moscoviss elle est disponible en
VOD sur notre site internet publsenat.fr
bonne journée à
tous